all right um
it being a
couple minutes past 10 o'clock it's time
for us to get started
those of you in the audience and
sitting and paneled
what we're going to do is we're going to
go through hb 103 fn because
it was scheduled for last hearing and we
just never got to it so we're going to
we're going to do that first there's
some issues to work through there
and then we're going to go into 1677.
now those of you who aren't on division
three
for
i i respect you as individuals if you
have something you want to ask
you know go ahead i think if we have a
vote we'll probably limit it to the
folks from who are here representing
division three though
um
so
my goal
is to
get through 103
in an hour or less
and and and
in order to do that
we're going to need uh the department to
to come up and and get us started
and then
i think representative irf
has spent a lot of time
working on an amendment and so
with with the department uh still at the
table
uh i'd like to be able to ask you
questions as we walk through the earth
amendment
and to see what you know about it and
what you think the implications of the
amendment are
there is a similar bill to this
in
the senate uh senate bill 422 fn
um i i might do something a little
unusual and and pass this out because
this is kind of a competing bill and so
one of the things that
i need to figure out and i i would
benefit from having input from division
three certainly
uh
is
what to do about their bill and 103
whether they should be merged or what so
so we'll take a look at that
um
and so with that
uh we're ready for the department to
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee henry lipman the medicaid
director for the record
good morning dr sarah finney medicaid
mr chairman i could
you mentioned
422 i don't know if the version you have
reflects
the amendment in committee um
where they
wanted to add some language um
to have the 1500 cap similar to
what
i think uh representative erf's uh
um amendment i don't know if the
language is the same but that was a in
committee uh when they voted uh
at uh house i mean uh senate finance um
i think the odds are are good uh because
the version i have says as amended by
where would you like us to start
well i
sent dr finney
an email i don't know if you saw it
emphasizing that this is a
if you all could just walk through the
bill
with an emphasis
on the financial inflows and outflows
that's that's what our primary concern
is i
we we have a division three has a deal
with hhs
um in the past we
the two committees
uh operated with a firewall between them
they did policy we did finance
and with the
agreement of chairman pearson
uh i i've i've encouraged them to think
about the financial implications of any
policy bills that they're seeing and
then similarly he said you know we
shouldn't be funding bad policy
so uh so we have our primary lane of
responsibility which is
um
the financial part and that's where i'd
like you to focus but if we dabble in
policy along the way uh that's okay
representative would you mind if we
fielded your questions first and then
um went through a little bit further so
so it's your testimony
and you can do whatever you want you got
a micro hot mic and and uh what i gave
was just sort of
some uh
teasers to make sure that that that that
i had communicated the distinction
between us being a policy committee or a
finance committee and i just
that that was really the purpose of my
email
very good i think just would emphasize
one of the the cost control measures
that i think you'll see
um that was reflected i think in the the
senate's uh finance committee amendment
and representative erf's
amendment is that you know
structurally putting in a cap of 1500
and that if that were to
to change that that we would need to go
through a process of getting fiscal
approval and gnc approval i think you
know where we understand in terms of
where this
dental benefit has um
not got over the finish line has been
concerned over costs and and we want to
be um up front that we're we
we get that and we want to work with
the committee to make sure that you have
confidence in the and the cost component
of this
the one of the factors that
was identified is you know how do we
um
you know in fact limit expenditures um
uh benefit would be limited to certain
groups and then again on medical
necessity i'll let
dr finney describe it further
you know one of the limiting factors was
to say that the denture benefit would be
available for individuals in the
dd abd and cfi waivers and nursing
facility residents so that is one
self-limiting factor there
okay so could we avoid acronyms i'm
we're
not as familiar with it as you are and
plus we have the public listening okay
the developmentally disabled wave
choices for independent
living
waivers
and then also nursing facility residents
would be um able to have the denture
and it that is also subject to medical
necessity so for instance if someone is
only missing one tooth they may or may
not really qualify for some type of
replacement if it is not
you know hampering their ability to chew
and function
so
you know that's an important thing to
understand that there does have to be
some
medical reason why the replacement is
necessary
are you
this i just am curious how granular
uh we've gotten uh do we know what the
incremental
projected cost would be of just the uh
the denture part of this bill
by limiting it uh my recollection was
about a half a million dollar savings in
terms of the annual cost
to
to this group okay so we we save it all
if we don't pass the bill i'm so i'm
curious what what the incremental cost
is is the incremental cost of the
dentures a half million a million a year
what do you have any numbers on that mr
lipman um if you give me a moment i'll
see if i can pull it
i just want to get that stuff into the
record and it will also vary with the
population you know
um
so it is going to be an estimate based
on
you know the pool of individuals that
another point that we did want to make
um because sometimes there's um a
difference in what people
see as the adult benefit and the
children's benefit
the children's benefit or the pediatric
benefit that we have always had here in
new hampshire actually covers
individuals up until the day before they
turn 21.
so the individuals that we are talking
about for this adult benefit are 21 and
above
and so
we need to be very careful when we look
at
enrollment numbers
that
are are
given by the department that we divide
the population according to
those ages
um in in some instances folks think that
once a an individual turns 18 or 19 they
are then considered an adult and in some
ways they are but in terms of the dental
benefit that we have here in state
and another way that
the benefit is being limited is by the
cost sharing
that
was
put into play in this benefit
and
the specifics of that cost sharing are
that individuals who are over 100
percent of federal poverty level
would make a 10
co-pay based on the cost of the visit
and that amount that they pay annually
is capped at 5
of their annual income
and that that includes any type of
medical co-pay that they have it would
not just be from the dental benefit
so for example if an individual is also
having to make co-pays for pharmacy
costs that has to be brought into the
calculation of how they reach that five
percent
so
do we currently have in-law the
co-pay for pharmaceuticals for medicaid
is that already in the law we do um it's
a de minimis one really it's a dollar or
two dollars per prescription um
currently so in terms of
absorbing a lot of the
the five percent of income is it's
unlikely to do so except someone who's
on a lot a lot of medicines
okay um
it's either a dollar or two dollars is
the uh co-payment on prescriptions
and then for the dental visits it would
be 10
of whatever the the cost of the
procedures are that day so so if it were
a 200 procedure they'd pay 20.
and then could you just
talk us through um
who's who's going to do the collections
who's going to keep track of uh whether
the ceiling's been reached how how what
are the mechanics of that
so um in testimony
i think earlier in the the process here
i don't think it's uncommon for
if it's done through the mcos if that's
what the
approach is that they they're able to
they're able to do that if it was done
through
a an entity like a delta dental which is
a sort of a freestanding
unit that both
parties had indicated that that
something coordination of benefits is is
not something that is uh
foreign to them and and would be able to
be done so in terms of tracking whether
they're up against the the limit um
there'd be obviously coordination
between the department and the
and the
either the mcos or the dental mco
and in terms of collecting the actual
dollars
that would be at the
the provider level um that makes up
their payment so if they were entitled
to a
a 200 payment the 20 would be collected
from um
from the patient
um and typically you know if you
people who have uh commercial insurance
that you know many of the practices
expect the co-payment before the service
um
and i would see that
it would work
somewhat
similarly so
so somebody's going to have to receive
their
financial information like their annual
income and all
which
opens up some privacy concerns can you
just
to talk a little bit about
what we're going to do to
respect privacy
of this financial information or or is
this a new issue or just something we've
already been dealing with in other areas
it's something we already deal with i
think is part of applying for medicaid
you have to make
financial disclosures to determine
that we wouldn't necessarily be
disclosing someone's
income directly um
to anybody other than within the
department in terms of just accumulating
what would be a threshold would be what
would be going on behind the scenes
so so the receptionist that's going to
or the administrative assistant who's
going to receive the patient's money
at the point
at the point of care
how would that
administrative assistant know whether to
collect 15
or 22 dollars and 20 cents i mean if if
it's a 10 percent it's got to be
um that that sort of seems to want to be
calculated at the point of care
right um and so
you don't need the their income to
calculate whether the
what the 10 percent would equal to it it
would be that if you collected a a
copay in it
say that the 10 percent and it was
greater than
and it turned out that they had been
paying a lot of other things
then then there might they might either
look up in the system um
providers can go in the system and look
up a patient's situation or they may
potentially after the claim is processed
and adjudicated may need to make a
refund uh if they collected too much
similar to commercial insurance where
you have deductibles and co-pays that
and and and limits if you will on how
much out-of-pocket cost someone has
all right have you
have you told us everything that you
wanted to tell us coming in here today
um i think we had some some more that we
wanted to uh
to address and i'm i do have denture
information i just need i have a detail
level i just need to do a calculation
while sarah's telling you something else
all right
i believe one of
one of the other questions
that you had was
to specify what the federal share would
be
versus the state share
so
in general terms for this benefit the
standard medicaid
population is a 50 50 match so it's 50
federal 50 state funds
for the expansion population which is
granted advantage um it's a 90
federal share 10 percent state share
and that 10 percent comes from
the health
trust fund so it's it's not a general
and
just from a population standpoint our
assumption is there'd be 51
143 people who would be
having their coverage through on the 90
level and 37 085 people who would be at
the 50
level
at
people who will be where the state would
be collecting the 90 percent match was
and where this where we would be
receiving the 50 match would be
37 085 individuals
would you remind me um
when and if
the
expanded medicaid sunsets when
when does that go away december of 23
unless there's an action by the
legislature
and then so based on this your
understanding of this bill would that 51
000 or so just drop off of eligibility
if if there was not and a continuation
yes
do you have more you're prepared to tell
us
i did want to share with you according
to the cost estimate for a full year of
coverage for the standard population the
cost to the state is 5.58 million
so that's 50
and then for uh the expansion population
is 1.32 million for a full year
now the way the bill is written there is
an implementation date of april 1st 2023
which means that there's one quarter
expense in fiscal year 23
and so
for that quarter the state portion of
the standard population would be 1.4
million
and for the expansion population would
be 0.33 million
1.3 million for the expansion cost
estimate for the population was that 5
million
5.58 for the standard if if you have
that in writing if you could hand it to
so i think pent up demand is one other
factor you wanted us to address but
the current funding of a medicaid
expansion grant advantage program
that the premium tax that's collected on
those policies because their commercial
policies the two percent tax that
applies to all policies in the state
that that
that tax
grant advantage program is used to
offset the cost of the program
similarly it could be done in this
instance as well that the the tax would
amount to a little over 400 000 on when
it's fully implemented and it's paid
the taxes paid
the first tax payment that if you if we
were to
continue that practice would be um not
and so i think the other question you
had was related to pent-up demand and
the factor that
was um
uh included in there and sarah you might
talk about that just a moment
um when the the pent-up demand was
calculated in this cost estimate um the
actuaries are basing that on a typical
medicaid population which is going to be
different than a commercial population
so
in the patient mix within the group of
individuals that's going to be insured
we know that this population is coming
into the benefit with heavy needs
because they haven't had the full
benefit prior to this
and so
that is included in our calculation for
the cost estimate
as time moves on
that will be adjusted
part of the reason is that this is
written to be a value-based benefit and
part of value-based benefiting is
incentivizing for both you know provider
and
and client
an improvement in oral health over the
time of the contract
so that
that that part of the contract will
drive down the pent-up demand because
they're going to be made
responsible the vendor will be made
responsible for making sure
that
they meet certain requirements that we
set in the contracting
of the benefit
so that year over year more individuals
are coming in having the preventive care
and the restorative care that they need
and then maintained throughout the
course of the year they don't just drop
out
and so
that will help to bring down that
pent-up demand and will adjust the cost
it's hard to tell is that going to take
one year two years three years four
years
um
you know obviously we want to see that
pent-up demand disappear as quickly as
possible
but um
you know that's i i can't do more than
estimate what that could be
so i think we've talked about this um
hallway conversation um
i i am
a believer that the pent-up demand isn't
quite as large as we might otherwise
anticipate because one of the mcos
providing 22
of the care has been providing a dental
benefit and they experienced some
adverse selection when they first made
that dental benefit available so
i'm good with the conservative estimate
that you all have put together that's
the right way to go no surprises or good
surprises so but i i i just think our
actual experience we're not it's not
i think that you're right in terms of
the
trying to be conservative about what it
could be so that we don't um
underfund the situation um
uh but also um you know since we don't
have experience you know having to rely
on
other states experience you know through
our actuary to develop that estimate
i did
look at the detail on the the dentures
in the waiver populations
the the use rate is expected to be um
eight
individuals per thousand enrollees we
we're talking about the 37 000 enrollees
so it's uh eight
eight times 37 is the would be i'll give
you a number in a second representative
while um but just so you understand how
i'm coming up with the number um it's
basically eight
exp expected eight times per thousand
people enrolled so we're talking about
um individuals who fit that category
and um
so in terms of what the the cost based
on the actuaries number would be about
175 000
for that population annually taking into
account
administrative costs and taking into
all right thank you
again if you've got that written down
somewhere that helped the clerk make
sure we got that accurately
so
um
i i'm assuming you've said everything
that you intend to say today uh because
i'd like to open it up for uh questions
from other people just to make sure sure
that would that'd be great and i i guess
just would close with saying that uh i
think the range of amendments that we've
seen are all ones that we could work
with um
to deliver a cost-effective benefit with
cost controls
great i i want to i want to have
representative earth well wait a second
division three does anyone have any
questions about hb 103
you'd like to ask now
all right so representative erf do you
want to walk us through your amendment
uh specifically what
do you see uh
thank you mr chair
so i'll be referring to
my amendment
what i refer to as the edwards amendment
which we also received and then hb103
itself
and i'll be describing the changes
between my amendment
and both the original bill as amended by
the house
and the edwards amendment that we
received prior to the last
meeting the edwards amendment addressed
the changes that we agreed to at the
meeting prior to the last one many of
which were being discussed by uh mr
lipman and dr finney here today
so the first change
is improved wording
for which i owe thanks to mr ripple who
worked with me on on this
um so referring now to my amendment
these changes appear on page one
towards the bottom
lines 21
to
27. and lines 31 to 32
and then page two in lines five and six
so
could you pause while we look at 21
through 27 since you highlighted those
yes and i'm actually going to address
each of those sections individually you
go for it i'll stop after that if you
want me to go for it
so
now that dhhs is moving into a con into
the contracting phase
as the work group has put forth the
recommendations
the description was changed
to correspond to this phase of the
process
essentially the word model
was changed to contract or organization
as appropriate to reflect this is the
contracting phase
with an organization
so this can be seen on page one
lines twenty one to twenty seven
what's referred to as section two the
first seven lines of section two
have been rewritten to make these
changes
these correspond to page 1
lines 20 to 26 of the original bill as
amended by the house so i'll gladly stop
here if you'd like for a moment you want
to look at those um
if if you could just clarify
what
with some precision
what do you think changed
um the word model yeah changed to
contract to organization essentially
so if you look at back at 103 the
original bill is amended it talks about
a model and so on and so forth we're
really not we're not in that mode
anymore we're talking about establishing
contracts with organizations so is it
fair to just consider that a semantic
cleanup i would say that's accurate and
if
mr ripple wants to nod his head
yeah since you wrote this
and the department doesn't have an issue
with that you've seen this you've
thought about it okay go ahead i don't
could you could you point the line
the word content will come in the next
there's some more lines that change with
regard to this change
so the change you see in the first three
lines there's relative to organizations
so the last two lines there section
three
lines 31 and 32
similarly they were
rewritten
again just for clarity and to talk about
organization
now the next line is where you'll see
contract pay i'm sorry the next page
line five and line six
so in line five
for the appropriate model it was deleted
and it simply says now capitalized rate
capitated rate excuse me for the
contract as was in the original and on
the next line where it said used to say
managed care model now says managed care
organization
okay so the second change
as it relates to the edwards amendment
on page
the amen that amendment replaced
and other services
as determined by the commissioner
with a reference to current dental
technology codes you may recal recall
this we had a pretty long discussion
with dr finney um about this
and when i dug a little deeper into that
with the help of dr finney and mr
lippman
it turns out these codes are not
generally available to the public
as they're behind the paywall pretty
expensive baywall
on the web
dr finney agreed that the dhhs could
make the updates
uh to the relevant cdt codes available
on dhhs
dhhs's website
and page 2 of my amendment
lines 26 to 27
reflect this you'll see the last
sentence there
says annual updates to the cdt and sorry
for the academies but that's as it is
shall be made available
on the department of health and human
services website
may i ask the department question of
course okay so
what what do we think about
the likelihood that in the next 10 years
the cdt references will change and we're
going to and given that we're being so
precise in this bill does that mean that
we're going to have to come back and a
future legislature is going to have to
update the statute
no i think the only way there might be a
change is that in dentistry we may start
using diagnostic codes but that would be
in addition to the current dental
terminology the american dental
association owns that code set yeah and
it is
the best way to describe every single
procedure that we're doing and i
personally would be shocked
if that ever changed that it because
it's
the standard for describing procedures
and is used throughout the insurance you
know industry it's not just medicaid or
commercial
everyone is using those codes okay
thank you
do you want to go on
yes sir so the third change is on
uh page three
um at the top
and this is referring to my amendment
uh lines one
two three
a new section five
is added to the list of dental services
dental services being the section we're
in
clarifying that the annual
individual the individual annual benefit
is capped at fifteen hundred dollars per
year
with an allowance for adjustment with
approval
of the fiscal committee and governor and
council
this fifteen hundred dollar per year cap
is
exclusive of preventive services
and this cap is already incorporated in
the plan developed by dhhs
and i'll pause here mr chairman if you'd
like to
okay the fourth change
uh is i'm going to describe as follows
so given that this new medicaid
given that this is a new medicaid
benefit this entire process here
it seemed reasonable to incorporate all
relevant parts of the benefit
into a single place
so there's no need to refer back to
previous chapter law in the future
remember the future maybe 10 years 20
years from now
to this end
the work group language of the current
chapter law is repealed
and reenacted
in a new section 4
on page 3
lines 24 23
to 37
and then continuing on page 4
lines one
okay
then go ahead and
this is a section that you've you've
worked with mr ripple and we've
validated that this uh comports to what
we need to do to clean up the statutes
so as mr ripple extracted this from the
chapter law
and put it in here and again he cannot
thank you
okay
so the final
uh change
also on page four line seven to nine
is a new roman excuse me roman numeral
three subsection
which sunsets the work group when their
work is complete
based on the selection of an approach
for administering the medicaid dental
benefit
and that concludes my
statement of the changes
uh thank you i'm i i'm i'm probably
confusing myself with the effective date
on
page 4
lines 12 through 14.
uh i'm i was expecting to see
april 1
2023 written in here somewhere and mr
lipman
you may remember that i think they were
the work that we have to do to get the
state plan in effect
not the the actual effective date of the
the benefit was where that was
suggestion was made in the last work
group session we had with you
right did you have homework to do to get
it ready by one april yes okay but is do
we need one april in the earth amendment
it's listed somewhere described
somewhere is maybe one of the key
[Music]
it's on page two line five of the bill
the public i'm just wondering if um
the sponsor has if you've consulted with
a sponsor around
these changes and
how the sponsor and how the health and
human service committee feels about it
i i was just about to walk through that
very thing okay do you have any other
questions nope that's just like okay so
we'll go in order with the department
and then i'll go back to representative
shapiro who has been bird dogging this
thing for a long long time along with uh
professor representative jeff salaway
before him so so we have a legacy here
um to the department uh the the question
is
um have you
are you comfortable that you've
participated in this amendment process
brought forward by representative irf
and are you comfortable with the that
these changes are good and effective
yes
uh
representative shapiro
dr finney if you do you want to also say
yes or no i would love to say yes and i
appreciate all of the time that everyone
has devoted to trying to work this out
and to understand and give us an
opportunity to answer all of your
questions
thank you yes you're very welcome you've
been doing great work so uh
representative shapiro there's a mic
along the side here why don't you just
sit
thank you mr chairman um i remember when
we put an appropriation in last year for
a dental benefit and you got up on the
floor and said that it wasn't vetted
properly or adequately now we've really
vetted this um
tremendously so i think um we've
certainly um
examined this in ways that we hadn't
examined it that at that point um
and i want to thank um representative
erf for a lot of clarifying language um
especially the 15 putting the 1500 cap
in
which is what the
actuarial estimates were based on and so
looking back i it's hard to believe that
we didn't put that in
earlier because that is a
significant part of describing the
benefit so i thank you for that my my
one question
and i think this is just um
wondering about the intent
of the
change on the top of page three
i wanted to change that cap
or are we are we
inviting them to kind of renegotiate the
whole thing
um
should it go before those committees
can i respond
so the intent and this was
in uh
discussion with dr finney and um mr
lipman
that this is a benefit that's
obviously well i imagine in perpetuity
and that that 500 cap over the years
decades will need to be increased
more likely than not and rather than
restricting
uh the state to have to come back and
get new legislation
this was decided as the most efficient
way to allow them to come
and get that cap
adjusted rather than having going back
to the legislature and rewriting the law
so to speak and yet still providing some
control
over the changes over time
and i would defer to them to speak
directly to that if
that would help
well
thank you um that seems to make perfect
sense to me and um
i'm i'm really in agreement with all the
changes that have been made i think they
did not change the substance
substantively the benefit in any way and
i think in many ways they make
improvements in clarifying things
thank you
and based on your work uh with
hhs um
are you comfortable saying whether or
not you think the policy committee would
i think they would be absolutely fine
with it all right
does that address your questions
yes and thank you mr chair yes um i also
did speak with the chairman of hhs and
did go over the benefit with him as well
at the amendment with him okay well
great thank you
so so the other
i i i would have felt comfortable
getting division three uh sort of on the
record
today
on what the house has done
um
but i i have to tell you that uh i just
today became aware uh for the first time
of senate bill 422 fn
and um i'm i'm told that this is
extremely similar
to what we've done but they've got a
different funding source other than
general funds
and because i've not read this uh i i'm
i i could you give us
your view on what sb 422 does that this
in terms of the
um
has the same 1500
cap where it would differ is they do not
limit the denture benefit
and they do not include
the cost sharing um that's included in
in representative earth's amendment or
um
other amendments that the committee has
considered those i think would be the
key differences um in terms of the the
range of benefits other than than
denture i think they line up pretty it's
the same the same
it was again
changes
so the the the differences would be
that
um
there's there's no limitation on on
denture to a specific population
the the similarity is that they both
have the fifth to be solidified on what
the what the cost uh of coverage would
be
all right so um we we did put this on um
hb 103 on the on the calendar for us to
discuss on the first of march
i i think we've go
go ahead just one other point in terms
of what the difference in the cost
estimate um so the the state share under
um representative erf and and hp 103 has
been
6.91 million on an annual basis the the
if i'm remembering correctly it's 7.45
million
again if you have those written down
it'd be great for us to see the
difference between the senate and house
estimates
um
did you get them
4.175
all right
so so
mr ripple did you did you want to make a
comment
he whispered in my ear one other point i
should have made is the the financing
mechanism um
contemplates using the uh settlement
right proceeds from um centene
settlement that the state had uh
minus the
an amount that's necessary to sort of
complete the
a portion of the
um what was the damages in terms of
paying back to the federal government
their share so it's about roughly around
18 million of the 21 million or 18 and a
half million the 21 million would be
used to help fund the dental benefit
thank you
so um
with that i i think
what i'd like to do and this is uh this
is open to some discussion
is um
i'm i'm i'm favorably leaning towards
accepting the irf amendment
uh the
senate bill
and of course we're going to vote on all
this and discuss it but but i'm just
letting you know where i'm at i i i'm
i'm favorable towards the irf amendment
i on the on the senate bill
on page two
starting at line 32 and i'll be giving
this to you there's a section on the
settlement fund that was just referenced
and um so
so what i would do left to my own
devices i think is to take 103
and append into it another amendment
maybe amend the irf amendment i don't i
don't know how to do this mr ripple can
help us with this um
is is to take
the settlement language and include it
in hb 103
i i would
i
am very much opposed to expanding the
benefit beyond what 103 has done i think
we've spent a lot of time on it
more time than the senate probably has
um
so so i i like the sculpting of sorry
it's my housekeeper that she's important
but not that important
um so um
i just lost my train of thought though
so
so i want to i i think i want to keep
103 as the shell
i i like the irf amendment and i want to
take the settlement money and and put
that into 103
and that's and that's what i'd like to
take to the finance committee for
acceptance and i think we can do that
in
something like an executive session of
division three
on the first of
march
um and with your help mr ripple of
course um
so that's where i'm coming from what
representative weiler says he concurs
what do you think representative that
makes sense to me as well yes okay
representative bean i see you shaking
your head uh representative long do you
have an opinion on this i know that
you're sitting in today for
okay representative walner i'm good i
think it sounds okay you're good with
that that approach okay
and and so representative rogers you're
okay with that
okay
so and there's no reason or is there a
reason for the department to disagree
with this approach
no there's not okay representative
shapiro
i don't really understand the
implications of where the funding comes
from but it's um if the department
thinks that that's
a good result that's fine with me i i
think it actually helps um the
likelihood of passing the bill because
there's an identified source of funds uh
so that we're not
taking it out of general funds in the
near term so we've got a two three four
year
run rate that is supported
i would definitely support it yeah
okay um
any final words of wisdom for us
just appreciation and thanks for working
with us okay all right and um
with that uh i'm going to close today's
hearing on hb 103
um and we will reconvene on it on the
first of march we're going to bring in a
another amendment that respects
representative irf
and respects the senate's source of
funding
so
um
all right
uh
mr ripple i think on the calendar i did
i put um that we would start
with 1677 at 11 a.m
i i may have done that or did i just
sequence them
okay
so
yeah so let's um let's go ahead and take
a five-minute recess the attorney
general and and attorney ramsey are in
the hallway i think and and then we'll
start with uh
mr
i i i've been told that if i try to
sound italian
i might be able to pull it off but
uh
it being well after the five minute
recess
we're going to go ahead and open the
and consistent with the the promised
last hearing we're going to hear
first from the
the victims rights
advocates today
and i i think we have two that want to
speak
i i i understand we also have a member
in the
citizen in the audience that wants to
talk about right to know
uh so we'll we'll invite her up uh maybe
third
and and then we'll bring the attorney
general and uh senior attorney um for
the department uh over to uh sort of bat
cleanup so that's that's where i'm at
well welcome
did you did you get a chance to sign in
there's a
i didn't but i also have a question i
had heard a week ago that we may also
have somebody here to just explain what
a structured settlement is are we going
to be able to hear from that person
today
is that is that
what mr early is doing yes yeah
so yes
okay
since we don't have to operate one as a
committee i i i would like that to be a
succinct training session for us so that
we get the highlights um
excuse me mr chairman yes uh
could you ask the ag to hand out the
amended version
so that we would you like to do that now
yeah okay okay that way
all right and so
so since i'm asking you to do some work
also if you'd like to use the table as
you're writing your notes you're welcome
to find a seat
okay all right
oh i don't think i think i was supposed
to hand these out
uh the the the one that was sent out
last night was not numbered
you know the the sides weren't numbered
okay while we're passing that out i'll
do some administrative notes for the
clerk and for the public
um
we we had asked for a written testimony
i think we got that from you and we've
got some written testimony also from
mr early
and
so the clerk will lean heavily on those
uh
if if you would
if you would just take any sort of um
supplemental notes so we can keep track
of what documents we received
and and then when the attorney general
starts walking us through the change
document um we'll go in sequence like we
did last time and rather than having you
record
uh mr clerk all the all the things being
said
if you'll just sort of
time stamp when we're talking about
particular things so that the public can
use it as a table of contents or a
reference so they can actually listen
quickly to the part of the testimony
they want to hear
is that do you understand because that's
okay
all right so it seems like the wrestling
is done and so
there we go okay thank you
uh dave vissenanzo
for approximately 500
child victims of the ydc
thank you again for the opportunity i
really appreciate you let me go first
this time
i'm going to still try to keep it brief
and to the point
i want to preface it by saying i i only
received the
latest draft from the ag's office late
yesterday
um and i
jim hadem and i my partner worked late
last night
putting together this summary of
testimony
um but i read it again this morning and
i realized you know i have more to say
but i
and i i i'm gonna ask you if i can have
an opportunity in the next day or two to
amend this or edit it or put it in
another form so
uh there may be a few things that i want
to add to it
i i think that's fine let let me go over
the timeline to make sure i'm i'm clear
with my chairman okay uh madam chair
what i think
we're asked to do division three in
division one
is to try to
exit from this committee with a
recommendation a document
that we
give a recommendation on so that the
full finance committee can get it
shortly after the 1st of march and then
we're ready as a full committee to vote
on it is that the timeline
and
i guess we might also say that we've got
another hearing on our work session on
the first
right i i've got that we we're going to
meet again on the first of march but if
our
expectation of the deliverable that day
is a vote on a final document as a
subcommittee
i i'm just thinking that we need to send
the full finance committee
a document with our recommendation
uh yes you do but it probably won't
occur on the first
all right
i i truly hope we can try to do that
just to keep from log jamming but but
thank you for your flexibility i
understand we have a snowstorm coming
tomorrow but nonetheless we'll be
talking by phone my partners and i and
one of the things we've not been able to
do is talk to since last night talk to
any of our clients and that's uh we we
can only talk to
a few of them not not 500 so i don't
think i answered your question and your
question was do you have some
supplemental time to
revise and extend your remarks and then
and you do
okay i i would just ask you that you
continue to work with the ag's office so
that
they know what's going on because
they're helping us prepare the document
that we're going to talk about on one
march okay good so well i mentioned
friday because i think maybe by the
weekend we'll have that supplement or by
monday so it's here in advance of the
tuesday session
is that fair
okay thank you um with respect to the
the latest draft from the ag i last time
i mentioned
the three central and essential points
that were
we considered necessary to a
victim-friendly resolution of all this
litigation
and the first was
that it include
all the victims not just a subset and we
don't want to discriminate against
victims
based on the type of harm rather than
just the fact that they were harmed
that's one the other is the independence
of the administrator
and the third was that we asked that
victims not be required to as a price of
admission to the process
be required to waive or give up their
judicial rights
it seems to me that we've made
significant progress on two of those
in the latest draft um the the first is
that i'll uh addressed is is the issue
right i'm actually not going to address
is the issue of uh moving
the selection of the r of the
administrator
from john formella from the ag
[Music]
and being selected
by the judiciary by the supreme court i
have to admit it's not something i ever
had thought of
uh when i saw it last night i said well
it's not the ag that is progress
uh for our clients and maybe that will
be more palatable to them
but i it's still too new and i really
haven't thought through the consequences
and the uh the ramifications i mean a
by making it a full-time judicial
employee i'm wondering if we aren't
limiting the pool
of talent uh from which we can draw i
mean i would view the the pool of talent
to be people who are actively doing
mediations for a living and arbitrations
for a living and are very good at it and
have done things that are similar to
this
i don't know if they're willing to if
they're willing or would be required to
give up that practice in order to take
this job i don't know maybe
we have part-time circuit judges maybe
you could maintain your mediation
practice over here and still go to work
for the state i don't know if it's
possible but that that'll be something
that i'll note in my comments in the
next few days
the other is that um
i have to talk we have to talk to our
clients i mean our clients uh
uh
the measure of success for this program
or this process is going to be on how
many of the 500
actually use it
and i've talked to you several times
about the the level of trust which is
actually very low
among our clients they view the state as
their their their abuser
the state is having harmed them not help
them and oftentimes that harm begin with
a judge
usually at the circuit court at the
family court level
uh you know a kid who may be
being abused at home next thing you know
he's acting out at school smoking
cigarettes and then he's skipping school
and he and his stepfather's only
apparent approach to parenting is
beating him so he's being beaten but
he's not telling anybody that and next
thing you know he he's skipping school
again and he's scoring weed and then he
goes back to the judge and the judge
puts him in ydc meanwhile the judge
knows nothing about the abuse at home he
knows nothing about all the other
problems the kid has
and the kids sitting there at 14 or 15
thinking boy
the judge has wrecked my life i'm
separated from my family and i'm in this
terrible place so a lot of our folks are
you know they hear about the judiciary
that's their experience
i for me
gord mcdonald i have tremendous respect
for gordon as the chief judge i've
mentioned that before he's my partner
for 17 years
a person of great integrity
i would trust gordon myself but it's up
to our clients to make that call and
i need more time to really think it
through and opine on it i will in the
next few days all right i appreciate
where you are in your thought process
and your communication process i i we
just need real clarity uh because we've
gone through two scenarios we've gone
through maybe three scenarios of how
we're going to appoint this
administrator ins and and so far
you've you've had concerns about all
three uh of the methods so
we we need you to know what we we i
would like to know what you're for
you know what you what you want us to do
um
and and we don't have to do that today
because you said you need to think about
it i do okay so think about it but but
we're just going to need clarity if yes
i'll try i'll do it as give you as much
clarity as i can all right i just can't
today on the fund administrator it's too
new right okay um i do have much more
clear ideas on the first point though
which is the scope
uh initial the initial draft said only
only victims of sexual assault and
now this draft is embroiding that to
victims of physical assault as well as
sexual
um
and uh what our
what we propose in instead is really the
abu the definition of child abuse that
dcyf uses in its manual
which is
broader than physical and sexual abuse
but also includes emotional abuse
unlawful usually in the form of unlawful
confinement solitary for weeks or months
at a time of a 15 year old
so that's what we we propose i think
it's progress but i would really like we
really want the solitary confinement
piece to be included
i have submitted to the committee
a fair amount of
studies and and uh expert opinions about
the harm to a child of this form of
emotional abuse
uh is probably the most significant harm
it may be counterintuitive but the
experts tell us that is true and that if
you put a kid in solitary for two three
weeks two three months
that does more harm to them than an
actual beating and it does more harm
than the sexual abuse that's what the
experts tell us i don't think it should
be excluded and so that that would be
our pitch on that one and i've i've uh
provided uh uh some annotation here for
a summary of our argument
uh we don't want to discriminate against
representative berger
thank you
in your discussions with your clients
do you have an idea as to
how many were put in solitary
confinement at ydc
and for how long
yes we do have some idea i can't put a
number on it but i will tell you the
number is very very high of kids who are
put into solitary confinement
it the numbers when we're talking
weeks and months
at a time those numbers are obviously
smaller but they are still very
significant
and i
view it as something where
kind of like a lot of you know some
parents who are tired they put their
kids in front of the tv i think at times
the way you handled a kid who was acting
out or was oppositional had trauma and
problems
lock them in a cell and they i think
that was a form of babysitting
and uh and it did tremendous harm to a
lot of these kids thank you i will add
though that i only i do not think that
the number of kids who only suffered
solitary confinement i don't think that
number is large it's almost always
accompanied by physical or sexual abuse
so the number is not great that are that
only sovereign solitary so we're not
talking about a large number being
excluded here the way the bill is
written but i don't exclude anybody i
i'm not going to give up on those folks
and i i don't think the i don't think
the state should either i think
states should recognize that that is a
very substantial and significant form of
harm and a form of negligence on the
part of the people that ran the ydc
and it should be recognized they
shouldn't be it doesn't mean their
lawsuits aren't going away anyway so
states gonna still have to deal with it
it's just that why not deal it in this
expedited uh and controlled and and uh
more victim-friendly process
do you think did you have a follow-up no
um
do you think you can provide input on
the definition that you would like to
see included so that the solitary
confinement it's in our it's in our
notes okay and then because i've i've
i've not read through all of this i just
i'd like to ask you
if um if you if there's a
distinction that is made in the
definition between solitary confinement
for an hour
for a day
for a week
you know i would think that there's kind
of an exponential curve yes to the
damage being done based on the amount of
time so so is that
that well that sensitivity to the amount
of i don't i don't think that this bill
can get to that level of granularity i
just don't i think that's for the
guidelines process that the bill
proposes
and that that is i think going to
require some deference
to the ag and to the claimant's
attorneys and to the administrator to
figure out those terms the the people
who are expert in this and do it a lot i
for instance now uh ydc's current rules
only since 2020
say that you can't put a kid in for more
than 15 minutes into solitary 15 minutes
now i'm not even talking hours i'm
talking
days and then weeks and then months and
i but that's something that can be baked
into those guidelines
uh when we actually get in the room and
say
what what do we understand to be a
inappropriate i mean there are times of
course i think they're rare when it's
when it might be necessary for the
security of the child or the security of
the institution you know of other kids
it's possible i'm not discounting that
possibility but that's not what we're
talking here we're talking about it
being
almost ubiquitous and routine and done
for punishment or just convenience of
the facility
or a way of breaking their will
and
my view that is not a humane way to
treat a child you don't break a child's
will by locking them up for a month at a
time in their underwear
just don't do that representative emmer
thank you
mr chair uh
are we dealing with records with this or
are we dealing with testimony i mean do
we have records that go back to show
that
the period of time somebody was in
solitary confinement
i have not seen
the state's records because they haven't
shared them with us and as far as i
understand jen
ramsey who is managing the civil side
for the state
may not have seen them either because
they are possibly tied up in the
criminal
investigation and there's a separation
between the criminal and the civil but
what i do have is
i have a lot of our clients records
which are from ydc and of course i have
my clients testimony
and they're you know they're telling me
and i you know at a certain level of
consistency
between these folks who don't know each
other but are saying this is the same
they all it sounds very similar you know
over time you know that that this
practice existed
and that there was it was it was a way
of
managing the facility
without really caring for the kids
and locking them up and and
making them
go to the bathroom in their cells
because there's no toilets in the cells
you know and not let them out to go the
bathroom and the stories are horrific
and these are people that don't know
each other and they all
sing what ends up being kind of common
themes
so i i have access to all the witnesses
which the state doesn't
um i don't know exactly how
comprehensive or granular the records
kept by ydc were because we haven't been
that we haven't been given access to
them yet
do you want do you want to go on with
your eyes yes um
i'm still on page one of my summary and
i'm looking at looking at page four line
three
um
just again this is just from last night
the state is now talking about the
possibility of including physical abuse
but
uh it clai says that the
as
interposed a a cap of 150 000 on any
case of physical abuse
as far as i know that number was pulled
from the ether and it's not tethered to
anything real
i don't think the state actually knows
what the damages are yet i don't think
the state actually the state hasn't
heard from the witnesses yet the state
doesn't really know what happened so i
don't know how
it could be anything other than
arbitrary to pick a number like 150 000.
you know you you received my letter
yesterday there may well be claims that
are worth less than 150 000 or 150 000
but there's also plenty that are worth
more than that and i don't know why what
person would participate if they felt
that
the process is going to lowball them you
know on something that is worth more
um
are you recommending the state go
without a ceiling
well the the ceilings or do you have a
different arbitrary number just to pick
no i don't have an arbitrary number but
a different number the number we propose
is the one the legislature has already
enacted there's two numbers one is for
individual events
and uh the other is for aggregate in
individual events and
um if i remember correctly i think the
statutory number is 325
per in per incidence maximum of course
it could be zero too but the max i think
is 325
and the uh aggregate total for an
individual say somebody has been beaten
15 times
or
put in solitary for a year or whatever
the aggregate is actually defined at rsa
14 colon 35b it's actually a formula so
i can't give you a specific number
because it very tends to vary every year
but it's it's tethered to
uh the general fund revenues
it's a tiny percentage of those revenues
but
it is uh
it provides a ready-made cap that the
legislature has already approved
for aggregate per-individual
cases
i don't know why we
why would we differ from what the
legislature has already made law i think
that's really what the cap ought to be
yeah i i i think you've raised a good
point okay
do you do you have another good point
i hope so
um
i i again i can't i have to tell of all
the things that we
are most concerned about it is including
the broadening the scope so all the
victims are included that's the most
important thing i've mentioned the
independence of the administrator and
the
uh interesting idea of of reposing it
with the the the responsibility of the
judicial branch
i i admit i had never thought of that
before and i'm going to have to think
about it for a few more days and i'll
get back to you on that
um
so to append to that though if if you
think about it and you don't like that
idea
i i would just ask you to come up with
something with a specific idea i will
okay thank you
um i was i'm on page three of my summary
but i think i've already covered it
which is the issue of the caps i don't
think these arbitrary
numbers make sense i've already said why
not
just go with what the legislature has
already made law
that's what would apply in the court why
why should it apply any differently here
i just don't see the reason um i'm on
page four of my summary
um
this is our third major concern and that
is that
um
that a victim who chooses to
wants to bypass the judicial remedy and
and or once it wants to at least submit
a claim and try to settle the case
um without having to go through the full
gamut of judicial
process
why should they have to as a price of
admission give up their judicial claim
we don't want to force victims to do
that at the
now this this this issue could be
influenced
depending on whether there is sufficient
level of trust in the administrator
we don't have that yet
and a sufficient level in the guidelines
that
will be developed we don't have that yet
and if if there are no arbitrary caps we
don't have that yet either but if all
those things fell into place maybe i
could recommend and persuade my clients
to say
you know it's worth the risk to you
because you're pretty certain we have a
pretty good idea of what the range is
where you're going to fall
and when you go to the army with the
administrator we have a pretty good idea
because the guidelines tell us and we
trust the administrator and we're
confident in his his or her
independence and there are no arbitrary
caps or the only arbitrary gaps are what
the legislature's already
uh allowed and those are those would be
sufficient for your purposes in this
process at that point we might be able
to say sure it's it's it's worth the
risk of giving up your judicial your
only leverage and entering the process
but there that's a lot of conditions
that we have we don't have yet
uh but right now uh it it's too risky i
wouldn't advise them to do it because it
could be a trap they end up in the
the uh process and the ag
makes a low ball offer the administrator
maybe agrees with it maybe changes a
little bit but it is a fraction of what
the person feels they're owed and if and
maybe their lawyers agree with them and
then you're stuck you gave up your
rights you're stuck with what they give
you and i
i don't think that they should be
required to do that as a condition of
participation what i would propose is
something a little bit different
and i have to admit that i am not
totally clear what the draft last night
actually means it does seem to me that
maybe it's inconsistent between page
five and page seven
maybe jen will be able to
prove me wrong that it's not
inconsistent but i i'm not i couldn't
figure it out i wasn't sure what it
meant but
maybe what
rights are waived is when
the individual finds out what the
proposed award is from the administrator
and they can say okay i'll take it now
or i reject it i'm going to go back to
to
to litigation i think at that point yes
that's fair to make them make a choice
but to make them make a choice before
they have any idea what they're going to
get i don't think that's fair and i
don't think many people are going to
agree with that
so i want to repeat that just to make
sure i'm tracking
what i think i just heard you say is
that
you would not want your claimant to
waive rights to another process
until they've entered this process
but they would have to exercise their
option before being told what the
monetary award would be that's how it is
now yes and that and that's what you
could support
no no that's what the way it reached now
no what i could support is the
administrator lets him know this is
where i'm coming down
i think
your case i think your case is worth 150
and they and now you know
uh and you make at that point you make a
choice i take it or i don't
and the administrator goes if he takes
it the minister goes forward finishes
the process issues a written award and
then you're that's done then you're done
and you've waived all your judicial
rights you give the state a release and
it's done
thank you for the clarification would
you take a question from representative
umberger
of course yeah thank you
uh thank you mr chairman
i think line three
says
they've inserted the word simultaneously
which means if you enter the process
you can't go to court at the same time
i mean yeah that that's that's i read
that that way too okay at first except
then i read page seven and it seems to
contradict that
well
i i guess that one of the things that is
concerning me is that
[Music]
hopefully resolution
will occur
before it goes to the administrator
in other words we're not
i'm not looking
for every case to have to go forward
to the administrator
and um
well that's not mine thank you that's
okay
yeah
and um so anyhow that's that's how i
read that is that
we're not suggesting
that
you uh you can't
uh decide to go to court
um
but you just can't do both at the same
time well and that's i see that's a
difference and if that's the case well i
think jen will probably clarify it i
read it that way in page five but then i
went to page seven and it says by
requesting a resolution proceeding a
claimant fully waves his or her right to
seek other relief in any other forum
including the judiciary
so i think by i don't that means at the
time of the claim or the time that you
go to the administrator but in any event
it's well before you know what you're
going to get
now again this could be possibly
uh affected
by a couple of other contingencies one
is do we trust the administrator second
do we trust the matrix or the guidelines
and three are there are there no
arbitrary caps if those three things
come together and we trust all those
three we might be more willing to wave
in advance because we have a pretty good
idea we're going to get a fair shake but
right now i don't think that we can say
that i don't think we have that level of
confidence and i wouldn't be malpractice
for me to recommend to my clients give
up your only leverage before you have
any idea what you're going to get
i don't think they'd be crazy to listen
to me and i would be wrong to give them
that advice
so i would urge the urge the committee
to consider
allowing the award to be communicated
maybe just verbally to the to the
claimant and give him or her a chance at
that point to say yes i accept or no i
don't and please or yes i accept please
go forward no i don't i'm going back to
court
so representative berger do you have a
follow-up
no no i'll uh always okay um and i'm
gonna go to representative lin in just a
second but i i just want to make sure
i'm understanding
your concern about the arbitrary limit
when the guidelines are issued there
will be ranges
included in them and
and as i understand the ranges it'll
have a ceiling and a
and a floor i i did the hand drunk but
but
you're you're not opposed to having a
a closed ended range
no i'm not and and it could be a range
or it could even be just a number that
is uh an estimate but i i think the
devil's in the details i i but i if it's
a range
i i think that that's fairly standard
we'd see that fairly often a range but
that we have no idea how that those
guidelines are actually going to come
out
um
whether they're they're going to have to
be agreed upon and then
i actually do have a point on that uh
the process of getting there but
uh again if we had confidence in the
guidelines and that the ranges were fair
and sufficient and there were no
arbitrary caps
then it's possible we would be more
inclined to or able to recommend to our
clients that they waive their rights in
advance before they know the
what the award's going to be
but okay so i'll go to representative
lynn i just wanted to say that i'm i'm
still a little confused on your concern
about arbitrary caps because if there's
a ceiling and a range it's effectively
capped
well if this but if the other if there's
other language in here that says the cap
on any violent act or any violence is
150 000 and it's a 450 000
case you know that's the range has got
to obviously be going to be between 120
and 150 because 150 is the max
so that's an arbitrarily low
and you know uh
standard
if those caps are removed and they just
become the root the stat statutory caps
that already exist well that gives us a
lot more room to play with and those
ranges can be set in at different levels
thank you for your patience i think i
understand what you mean when you say
arbitrary cap
uh representative lynn
yeah thank you mr chairman uh mr sonata
i guess the thing that i'm not clear on
is this if i i mean i think i understand
your position that you think
the
you think that your clients should be
able to go through the process including
uh sort of not coming to an agreement
between your client between your clients
through their attorneys and and the
attorney general's office
going to the administrator having the
administrator
issue a decision saying
you know i would award your client x and
then still being free to go to court is
that well i you know whether i don't put
the administrator to too much work
having to write an opinion or no no i
understand but but at some point and the
way this is typical in mediation the
mediator will say here's where i'm
coming out i've heard him i've heard you
and i've considered all the factors and
i i think that that 150 is a fair amount
sure no no i understand that but i guess
what i'm really saying is i mean your
free
what you if that if we in if we
develop the system that way
what i mean it seems to me it's not
really very much different than than
what the law is right now i mean you and
the attorney general could sit down
right now yeah and come to and and try
to work out a settlement and if you
weren't happy with it you could go to
court so right i guess what i'm kind of
want i mean if we were going to allow
that
my sense of what do we need this
legislation for why don't you just you
know well you're right why don't you and
the attorney general just sit down and
work it out and we can always do that
even with this legislation right right
and our judge shulman is already after
us to sit down for mediation now to push
us on that and but that's why we want
this process to be as much like the
mediation that we're familiar with
uh and uh
because otherwise our clients will
probably choose that over this
and um i think this is a better could be
a better process and could make expedite
things a lot and be better for the state
but i i think i i think it's unfair
to ask somebody
uh who's
all they have is it the judicial claim
and ask them to give up in advance that
one piece of leverage that they have the
only power they have
before they have some idea pretty good
idea what uh
what their case is going to be worth
with the administrator i just don't
think that people are going to do it i
don't think that i can recommend it now
again if the guidelines are well
developed and we agree to the guidelines
and they are
sufficient and the ranges
are are adequate
and we trust the administrator that
could be different that might make it
different but those are contingencies
that have not been decided yet
you know and that at that point we might
be able to advise
it's worth taking the risk go through
the process because you're pretty sure
to get something that's pretty fair but
right now we can't say that you know
so i also kind of relatedly and this is
going back to those guidelines uh and
one of the things that the giraffe last
night does is it it kind of
seems like an awfully elaborate process
to come up with these guidelines and
then it's not clear that the guidelines
are mandatory or advisory or
are they presumptively what the range
would be for a particular act or group
of acts it's it's not really clear and i
also note it um
the guidelines have to be developed
before the administrator is picked i
kind of feel like
it would be wiser to do it the other way
the reverse which is pick the
administrator and then the ag and the
council have to sit down and work on the
guidelines but they have the benefit of
input from a neutral third party the
administrator who is also presumably a
wise man or woman who's knowledgeable in
this area and will help them because i
could see these guidelines being very
difficult to come up with
and and the ag will come at it they're
going to lowball as much as they can and
we're going to try to get as much as we
can for our clients because that's what
that's the the what our civilized
society that's the set of incentives
that we've set up because
no they have no other friends except us
so we're there to fight for them and
that's what we're doing and the a.g
meanwhile is a duty to get the best deal
for the state so you've got the two
partisans hit button heads wouldn't it
be good to have an administrator in the
middle to kind of who doesn't have a dog
in the fight
to help them get to agreement on those
guidelines because i could see that
being a point at which this whole
process could break down the other point
i think where it could break down is
bringing the guidelines back to the
finance committee um i i don't i think
that's going to be a really tough thing
i think at some point the legislature
just got to trust
the experts and the parties to some
degree
uh based on expertise because how do
what's it going to look like it comes
back to the finance committee you're
going to be talking about very explicit
graphic physical sexual acts or abuse
abusive acts and trying to put a number
on them and subject it to a public
debate
and
what is this worth and what is that
worth and i don't
i don't know i see that as being very
awkward very unwieldy and of a decision
point that is another opportunity for
this whole process to break down
so i kind of see i feel that the way
it's proposed now is too complex too
many junctures at which it can fail
i wish it could be streamlined uh the
way we would do it and the way we do it
in front of judge shulman is we we
sit down and we'd have to argue it out
and the judge would probably act as a
well the judge probably wouldn't do it
judge would appoint a mediator and the
mediator would be a neutral without a
dog in the fight and help us get to
agreement and see the weaknesses on our
case or the strengths in the other
side's case and get to an agreement that
way but this has so many different
layers of approval
and discussion and i i just see it
failing if it remains the way it is
okay i'm going to go to representative
weiler here in just a moment but i i
want to comment that we we did talk
about the finance committee reviewing
these um
last session yes and uh it's not our
money
it's the taxpayers money yeah and so
uh i think what the thought was was
let's do this in a way in which it's
transparent to the public since they're
the ones writing the check ultimately
absolutely so
there's a finance committee we make
financial decisions we expect results we
have an audit division that we task with
bringing us the results
this you're bringing us forth something
that has no results except for you
does it cure the problem
does it help the victims
are they still going to be
ps ptsd at post traumatic stress and so
on nothing of that will change
and how do you assess which one is worse
off are you going to do a psycho
analysis of each victim to find out how
damaged each one in is that included are
you gonna have group therapy sessions
none of that's proposed you're just
looking for money what does the money do
nothing
as far as i'm concerned it's a waste all
we're trying to do is save time for the
attorney general and the courts by
offering
and you're just trying to expand it this
is ridiculous
to say oh someone's punished by
solitary confinement what precedent does
that set everyone in the prison can come
in here and sue us because they suffered
from solitary confinement i refuse to
widen this i i thank you mr g
thank you i i
i just want to say that um
in in these hearings our goal is to
collect information that we can talk and
talk about later and um i i
we don't want to berate
um
any of the witnesses and i i think we
got a little close
so thank you thank you
can i speak uh
uh mr chairman
oh sure i appreciate the comments from
from representative weiler i i and i've
looked i'm i could retire tomorrow i
don't need to be doing this i i figure i
got 10 good years left i want to do this
so passionately about what happened to
these kids
and i'm not going to be deterred
but i i appreciate your comments but i
do think they kind of illustrate my
point earlier which is
you know everybody's got an opinion and
i think if we
don't streamline the process it's going
to fall apart
and i don't think it should fall apart i
don't think i think my first goal of
course is protecting the victims and
getting them some form of justice
and you're right that money never is
sufficient it never is of course it's
not
but we can't undo the past the only
thing we can do is what the civil system
does and that it's a recognition of in
some way of
the harm and it's some form of an
apology to those kids who suffered at
the hands of the state for so many years
so i appreciate your comments but i do
think it kind of illustrates if if it's
an open
open field for conversation and
discussion and debate i'm not sure it's
ever going to get done um there has to
be some room room for deference to folks
who actually do this and who actually
talk to the victims and who have
expertise in the area i'm not sure and i
try to come up with a more concrete
proposal than those abstract notions i'm
talking about right now but i do want i
feel like i want to make that point or
if you put too many junctures in which
the process can break down then it will
all right i i don't i don't want to rush
you do you think you're you're done with
your main points
um i had uh one more
uh and it
i don't know that's a main one but it's
on page five of our summary
and this is um again i'm not
kind i'm not entirely clear about what
the ag is proposing here page 7 line 34.
the administrator's decision regarding
the claim shall be final and
non-appealable
and then certain provisions of rsa 542
will not apply
i think the concern here is the a.g
doesn't want an appeal
after the administrator makes a decision
and i agree with that that's fine with
fine with us
except i mean obviously if there's an
appeal based on a plain error a mistake
mathematical mistake something like that
or i i i still think you should have
access to the courts to correct it if if
there is such a a problem i don't
anticipate there will be
but our concern here
is because we are
uh putting together kind of a form of
arbitration
is that we want the award of an
administrator to be
a final and enforceable judgment
and i think that's the intention here
but i i have to say that i feel like the
language isn't that clear
and we've gone back and forth with the
ag several times and i i don't know if
we're talking past each other or maybe
we're not understanding but our goal
here is that once you have waived your
judicial rights and you've got an orb
you've got the administrator's award
that it is enforceable
and typically to do that you have to go
to court and have the court bless it
under the arbitration statute and say
yup it is now a final judgment i've
reviewed it
and
it's now enforceable
i don't know if we have to do that but i
want to make sure it's final and
enforceable that's all it's our only
concern how we get there i'm open to
open to suggestions but i did make the
comments in the margin
which i is our attempt at least to
provide some language that would help us
so i'm i'm hoping that when the ag's
office comes up to the table that they
can address that issue
all right yes
wha what else you got for that that's
those are the main points that i had and
and i i appreciate the opportunity to
comment further on the issue of the um
appointment of the administrator in the
next few days and i will do so uh but
those are the points i mean it's
not discriminating against any of the
victims
uh not making them give up their rights
uh uh unduly without having some idea
what they're gonna get
um and then the independence of the
administrator
uh all right uh thank you very much for
your testimony uh we will uh invite uh
mr early up
uh we have a
[Music]
so mr early uh
come on up and and um before you launch
into the lesson
would you tell us
why you think it's important for us to
know what a structured settlement is
before we get into what a struck what it
is let's talk about why you think it's
important for us to understand it sure
thank you mr chairman thank you
representatives i appreciate the time mr
chairman uh two questions one
i have a request of the attorney that he
comes in with copies of your testimony
for everybody on the committee please
because i know that it's been
there were a lot of pages involved with
your last
presentation for your testimony
so i would appreciate copies
of your testimony written testimony for
all members of the committee
excuse me uh robert do you know the
right there on the table i've got it
here that he did have them here for us
today and everything he referenced is
over there on the table okay i i
apologize sorry thank you uh secondly
could for the for the clerk could you
repeat your name in
for the record
thank you yep i'm a rep i i live in
windham new hampshire um i work for
wringler associates which is the
nation's uh largest structured
settlement provider uh and to answer
your question mr chairman um i'm i'm
here to speak on structured settlements
i believe uh the most recent
version of legislation that i was able
to look at last night includes reference
to structured settlements um i'm here
today
to uh to talk a little bit about what
they are how the parties involved
operate when a structured settlement is
utilized and answer any questions that
this committee may have
so for those of you who are not familiar
with the structured settlement it is
basically it's an alternative to a lump
sum
where a
claimant as part of an injury settlement
can receive their proceeds
in fixed and determinate tax-free
guaranteed payments as opposed to a lump
sum
i have worked with injury victims
insurance companies and personal injury
attorneys throughout new hampshire and
new england for most of my career
but our our industry has also been
involved in similar mass tort
legislations like we're talking about
today
we were recently very involved in the
michigan state sex abuse victims fund
we've also been involved in the station
fire victims fund the 911 victims
compensation fund
the boston archdiocese fund to name a
few so we are we're familiar with this
this form of of fund as well
um
a structured settlement exists primarily
for
someone who is
unwilling or want wants to have their
payments spread out over time
in a guaranteed tax-free manner and
that's the way that that structures
operate and they are often
very well utilized in in the types of
victims we're talking about with this
legislation
my services as somebody who who works
with the attorneys the victims and often
the insurers or in this case the state
is to customize that that
those plans
educate the parties about what the
process is
my services come at no cost
the entire award that goes into a
structured settlement is invested in the
annuity
and importantly
the state which which
in this case would be purchasing the
annuity on the victim's behalf
also pays no fees and has no ongoing
obligation
by a mechanism what's called a qualified
assignment i have materials to to
explain that a little bit further
the state has no ongoing obligation of a
structured settlement is entered into
they they are released just as if they
are issuing a lump sum payment
and the
the
obligation to make those future periodic
payments is transferred to the annuity
issuer all of the annuity issuers that
that we work with in the structured
settlement industry are a or rated
better uh companies by am best these are
life insurance companies um that you are
most likely familiar with companies like
metlife pacific life mutual of omaha
usaa um
the the my purpose here today is
especially now that there is reference
to structured settlements included in
the legislation as an option for our
claimant to
elect should they wish to go that route
is
to answer any questions that you may
have and
i'm happy to do that now
i i i have a question for you have you
seen the document that we uh received
today called hb 1677
second recommended amendment by a.g i
believe so yes i believe i received that
last night
okay and
are you satisfied that the language in
this document is appropriate
yes i i think that it provides the
option for somebody if they wish to go
that route to elect to do so and and
importantly the language that's in there
also protects the state uh there's a
reference to a qualified assignment um
under section 130 the tax code and and
from the state's perspective that's what
i wanted to make sure that was in there
as well to make sure that that
obligation is transferred away from the
state should somebody receiving an award
from the fund elected to do a structured
settlement okay so i'm i'm viewing you
as a a friendly witness that you've
you think that what the ag's doing is
perfectly appropriate and the right the
right words are in this
draft i i think that the language
specific to structured settlements
that's in the most recent version is
appropriate from my chair as a
structured settlement expert yes well
thank you for that um
are there any questions from the
committee uh representative weiler
what savings do you offer us or do we
make this payment
in totality up front
it it it
generally depends um
the savings are not necessarily
an aspect of it as much as
the award that the administrator would
would issue would be the amount that
that is
final
what what the victim then has the option
to do instead of taking that lump sum
um and then perhaps either mismanaging
it or you know whatever the case may be
and i think that's where there's a
secondary savings um in that by
providing them guaranteed fixed payments
as a form of income
prevents premature dissipation of the
funds which could also then prevent
somebody you know going on on state
services or things like that so i think
non-quantifiable savings in that sense
but there is also no as i mentioned no
obligation for the state um in terms of
ongoing obligation to fund those so that
the amount that the administrator would
award would be the same whether whether
thank you mr chairman um isn't it true
that if somebody elects a structured
settlement it saves the state the
administrative costs because within this
there's an option for the victim to to
take their payments over time even if
they don't go through you
and at least on the last draft i saw i
haven't seen the language in the most
current draft and if a victim elected to
take their payments over time
if if they elect to go through a
structured settlement through one of the
insurance companies doesn't that then
remove from the state all the
administrative obligations on that with
respect to dispensing the money with
respect to taxation all those kinds of
things yeah yes as i read the most
current form of the legislation as i
mentioned i just got it last night but
the way that that i understand it and
the attorney general's office can
correct me if i'm wrong is that
essentially there are three options one
is a lump sum the other is for the state
to fund payments installments over i
believe it's up to a period of 10 years
or for the claimant to elect a
structured settlement
of the two that require ongoing
installment or periodic payments um if
this the option that the state funding
those payments would require the state
to keep a book open to basically fund
those in the accounting that goes there
with um with the structured settlement
it it functions the same as if um as if
it were a lump sum so there there is a
full and final release on on all claims
um and the state closes their obligation
just as if they were issuing a lump sum
so from from the state's perspective
there's there's no difference in
accounting and ongoing obligation
follow-up
um so this as you may or may not know
the state supreme court has something
called rule 40 that pertains to
structured settlements with respect to
minors how does that fit into what you
offer
um i'm very very familiar with that um
as a
as a new hampshire resident and as a
structured settlement purveyor here rule
40 comes up on every single case that we
deal with with miners and i understand
that um miners are are not you know are
some of the claims will be miners not
all of them will be um rule 40 um
is is basically a list of um court
mandated
annuity issuers that we have to use when
miners are involved they are not
radically different than what we would
use with anybody else it's slightly more
restrictive there are about seven um or
eight annuity companies at issue
structured settlements i believe roughly
five of them are approved um under rule
40 for minors
the only other difference with with rule
40 cases is
i'm required to submit an affidavit to
the court rule 40 is is has to do with
the court's approval of the settlement
um when a structured settlement has
evolved um
my office will make sure that all the
documents are compliant with rule 40. uh
i sign an affidavit for every rule 40
case complying that the the annuity
meets the standards that are outlined in
that rule um and um
all of the companies that we use and
specifically the ones that are outlined
major u.s life insurers with very high
ratings and that that would apply not
just to minors but to all the cases that
okay i'm
i'm not seeing any other questions
uh do you do you believe you've uh told
us everything you think we need to know
i i believe so the one thing i i would
add is just in terms of what my role is
as as a structured settlement consultant
um you know beyond i wanted to make sure
i addressed what the state's obligation
or lack thereof would be but from the
victims perspective you know
one of the things that i do
is to make sure that future needs are
met
i am not a financial planner i am not a
wealth manager that is not my practice
the vast majority of the people that i
work with are people who
have never come into large sums of money
at one time
and
often need some assistance to make sure
that their future needs are met and that
is one of the things that i do
our industry has done several
dissipation studies over the years to
show what happens to somebody when they
come into a large amount of money in a
short period of time um as i'm sure
you're aware too though the most common
form of this is is with you know lottery
winners professional athletes things
like that
the vast majority of the people that
come up in these studies
the evidence shows that the money does
not last nearly as long as they expect
it to
and one of the things that a structured
settlement does is provide them with
guaranteed income
it is an extremely simple vehicle as i
mentioned it is an it's an annuity with
fixed indeterminate payments so the
payment stream is customized and my job
is to work with the the victim to
customize that payment stream to meet
their needs
but the payments are determinant they
are set on guaranteed dates the amounts
cannot change they they cannot be
altered they cannot be accessed early
and it is a it is a good way to make
sure that those needs are met over time
without them um
inadvertently
spending the money in ways that was not
intended
so my job is to work with them to
customize those payment streams and and
not the entire amount has to go into a
structured sentiment either
one of my roles um is to kind of figure
out what the immediate needs are if
somebody has
needs for housing or vehicles or things
like that it's an it's a voluntary
procedure where we can just kind of give
them that option
to provide those payments again at no at
no risk or no future obligation for the
for the funding entity
all right uh thank you very much for
your testimony appreciate your time
appreciate it an interest
and then with that i i think we've got
ms timmins
and then
just
provide your full your full name for the
clerk
thank you for the chance to speak to you
today i am anne-marie timmons i'm a
reporter with the new hampshire bulletin
and i'm also here on behalf of the
legislative affairs committee of the new
hampshire press association
so i just have a few brief points just
excuse me i didn't hear you clearly with
the mask
could you spell your name please sure
it's anne marie it's one word a
a-n-n-m-a-r-i-e
last name
and you're with representing whom the
new hampshire bulletin
news site and also the new hampshire
press association's legislative affairs
committee
okay thank you you're welcome
so i just had a few brief points about
the right to know law aspect of this
bill
i just want to start by saying our
constitution is exceptional in that it
puts in writing that there is presumed
an open access to government because
that is how you hold government
accountable and
i think the records in this case which
are preemptively clothed under the
proposed bill
are important because if i could offer
the example of the catholic church
settlement that the state engaged in
many years ago now
the attorney general decided in that
case that the best course was not to
take the church through the court
process but to release the records of
the church's handling of abuse claims
over
decades because it's important to know
what happened and how it happened and
that's how you find out and those
records were released thousands of pages
each one the names of the victims and
their identifying information was
redacted and so the privacy concern was
protected but the public
knew and understood how the abuse
happened
and what failed what how those victims
were failed
so that's why i think the case the
records here are important i see a
similar
i see it as similar
in that this is a state agency we know
that there are many victims of the
handling of this we should know and the
public should know what happened what
was the extent of it what did the state
know what did the state not know and how
were those concerns handled
the ag's office did and i appreciate
this make clear in the proposed
amendment or changes that we we have put
we were very clear that the settlement
the actual settlement in these cases
will be available to the public and i do
appreciate that inclusion i know that
was raised by the new hampshire right to
know committee and i am grateful that
they heard that concern
that is already part of the law so
while i'm glad it's in there
i'm not sure
it is necessary it doesn't resolve my
other concerns we do have a right to
know law that i think works well and i
say that
having used it for 25 years even when i
didn't get the records that i want
because there it requires a balancing
test there's records i want there's
records that the agency or town doesn't
want to give up and in the way attorney
visananzo mentioned that there needs to
be a neutral party that party is the
court and in that process the court
considers from from a neutral
perspective
what we want to know what is
considered private by the state or the
town and comes to a conclusion what
should be released and how and when
there is a record that
is partially
confidential
it is released with that information
redacted it does not require that the
whole document be redacted it's very
specific about that
and i think in this case just my last
point is that we are preemptively
excluding from public
record
records we don't even know yet
what they exist
i'm not seeking information about how
the attorney general
advises or handles the legal aspects of
this case but i do think we should
know
or easily have an access to ask for
records that show what happened in this
case and how it was handled and how it
wasn't handled and that happens through
the right to no law which i think works
represent amber
uh yes um
i guess that uh from one of the problems
is is that we are dealing with juveniles
and
how much currently are juvenile records
released
when you ask for them under the right to
know i'm just not sure thank you for the
question they are protected and so in
that case i think that is the court's
responsibility to look at is there any
part of that that could be
released
i don't think the name should come out i
don't think the dates of birth should be
released and that's the standard now but
what did happen to this group of people
who were juveniles and that might help
us understand because in this case they
were
especially vulnerable and so how did the
state handle those complaints as a group
you know not as an individual per se if
the court felt like that was
so
i'm just i'm just
trying to come to grips with this so
you would say that
um
[Music]
you you would go to court
to get the information that you wanted
or is it something that you think should
be part of
the process i'm just trying to i'm just
trying to come to grips with
we know this is dealing with juveniles
so the process yeah and it's hard to
know
a bit because we don't have the records
yet but the way the process works now is
we
or the public request a record um in
this case it may be the records
tied to a settlement of a particular
person
and
we would want to know what happened
generally in this case because i think
if you see
these cases as they stack up you might
see a trend or a pattern so in this case
we would ask for that record
the court may say no you can't have any
of it because there's nothing in here
that we can't that we could release
without identifying the person but in
the case of the catholic church
situation
the names of the victims who were
juveniles was redacted
their lo their addresses at the time
were redacted but we did know
how the grooming process worked we saw
letters back and forth to the church
that sowed we knew at the time that this
child
mother
complained and nothing was done they
moved that priest to another parish so
in that way we don't know who the child
is but we know
how there was a complaint raised at the
time by a parent for example and that
the church decided
to handle in a way that maybe wasn't
on the side of the victim in that case
you have a follow-up uh so miss timmons
uh
sometime i think prior to the previous
hearing
the ag's office
provided us with a an example
of the kind of settlement form that they
they would uh be completing
and what on it would be available for
the public and what would be redacted
have you seen that form
i haven't i had reached out um probably
not in the the right way i guess to get
some more information from the attorney
general's office and to share my
concerns but didn't hear back and i'm
sure that's just a matter of
getting lost and
enroute but i have not seen that
okay so let me ask
i feel like monty hall here uh
ag's office do you happen to have a copy
of that example redacted form that we
could get to miss timmons
oh there we go
that's that's that's fifty dollars for
mike
uh
okay door number three
you do you wanna take a look at that and
then come back up sure yeah thank you
that would be great all right uh and
have you looked at this second amended
draft that the ag's office has put
together
the the version that's on the table yes
and that that's where i see that they
did um
sort of respond to the request of the
right to know
group and say we understand that the
settlement so i guess that would be this
piece these papers here would be
available and that that's that exists in
the right to know a lot now but i do
appreciate them hearing that
okay so do you do you think at the end
of the day here you've got any specific
requests for language
modification i would like that section
removed
so just a
a wholesale deletion yes because i think
we have a process i don't think it's
necessary legislation because there's a
process in place that the legislature
has already
adopted and has left in place for many
many years
all right thank you for your answer are
there other questions representative
walls i see some movement do you have
no all right with that um thank you very
much if i could ask one question do you
want me to um respond in writing to some
concerns about that would that be
easiest for the committee or would you
like me to come back up so
so you're welcome to do it how you wish
i i i'm just wanting to make sure that
you've seen
the example that the ag's office has
already provided to the committee
so that any concerns that you still have
can either be addressed or
you know so if you if if you look at
that and you want to come back up we can
do that if you want to do it in writing
we can do it in writing i think i'll
take choice b i'd like to take it back
to the legislative affairs committee and
just have a quick look at it so we're on
the same page okay now mike do you need
your copy back okay because we have a
xerox machine next door
okay thank you
thank you thank you
all right so it is uh 12 16 so we're
we're getting deep into a lunch period
and uh normally i would just uh drive
through um
[Music]
that's probably the wrong phrase i would
i would just continue the hearing but i
want to make sure that if there's anyone
who has dietary needs where they have to
eat on schedule that that that we
respect that
has anybody got a
timing on a okay
can you do this in 45 minutes
or less
all right
okay and then and then that includes uh
picking up on the things that we've
heard from previous testimony today
okay thank you very much would the ag's
office step forward
and
[Music]
oh i i blew it i i did blow it you're
right come on down all right
thank you mr chairman for the record
john framela attorney general and with
me is jennifer ramsey senior assistant
attorney general
jennifer i have a question
your your last name is it s-e-y or s-a-y
i'm an e-y ramsay thank you for asking
all right so given the the charge to get
through this in 45 minutes if possible
what i thought i'd do is uh go through a
similar process as last time
we've handed out a a summary of the
second uh second recommendations for
amendment so a summary change sheet so i
thought i would use that as a guide for
our discussion so i'll go through that
and also
look at the specific language that this
summary sheet references
so these change just at a high level
these changes are based on what we
discussed at the last work session
they're also based on discussions we
have continued to have both with
claimants council and other
organizations such as the trial lawyers
and the structure the folks who are
talking about structured settlements um
and
and uh others who have wanted to have
input on this process so um that's
that's kind of where these come from
they they are also reflect our judgment
as to what we would recommend and what
we think
is workable for the state
understanding that the ultimate decision
is up to you all
so the first group of changes in this
second amended draft
is
are changes that are designed to go to
the concerns regarding the administrator
and the appointment of the administrator
the independence of the administrator so
that there can be trusted the
administrator
and as uh was discussed earlier by
attorney vicenzo what we have come up
with uh based on our internal thinking
discussions with some members of this
committee
and based on the the desire to have
independence is to have the
administrator
be a temporary employee housed within
the judicial branch
you'll see that first on page 1 lines 11
through 13
where we're just defining
you will see the real
substance of this on page 2
lines 20 through 38.
this is where we create the temporary
position the administrator who can be
either an attorney admitted to practice
in new hampshire or a retired judge
they would be a temporary employee
within the judicial branch
they would receive the same salary as a
superior court judge
and the appointment of this person would
be this is all in lines 20-38
the appointment of this person would be
a joint exercise between our office and
claimant's counsel and the supreme court
and what we have suggested is that we
would work with claimants counsel to
come up with a list of acceptable
candidates we would submit that list to
the supreme court and the supreme court
would make the selection
under that mechanism it's possible that
that we could just agree on someone and
the court would appoint that person if
we submitted a list of of one because
the language allows for a list of up to
five
but if we can't agree on one person the
other option is to at least agree on a
list from which the court would pick
so i know attorney vicinanzo said that
they would want to think about that a
little more before they give their
give their final feedback but that
we felt that that was potentially a good
way to balance you know the desire to
find a qualified person and to have that
person be independent
to have that person still be a state
employee somewhere within the state so
that we can control costs which we heard
concerns about last time so this this is
our attempt to balance all of those
things
obviously we we've put it in here so i
think it's a good suggestion but that
that will ultimately be up to you and
i'm sure we'll we'll talk about it
further when we've heard tony
visananzo's feedback
so before you leave this bullet um i
think uh we were asked two things we
were asked to make sure that
uh we had an adequate pool of candidates
to where we could get this filled and i
assume you believe that we can do that
under this legislation
and the second
was
whether or not
this was going to become a mutually
exclusive role
or if the person could maintain an
independent practice should they have
one have you thought about that second
one
so i i
what i don't know off the top of my head
is if
i know we have moonlighting
rules for state employees at least in
the executive branch that certain
full-time employees cannot have other
employment outside of their jobs cannot
necessarily receive compensation for
other jobs
i don't know because we've made this a
temporary employee within the judicial
branch i don't know if they have those
same rules
from my perspective if whoever the
administrator was felt that they could
do both
i wouldn't have a problem with that even
if they're a temporary employee of the
judicial branch maintaining a mediation
practice on the side but
i think that would be a conversation
between
i think that would be a conversation to
be had when we started working to come
up with acceptable candidates figuring
out who we thought would be workable
we'd talk to those folks
and if an individual felt that they were
interested but would want to maintain a
practice on the side and in talking with
that person we felt that that could be
workable we'd agree to have them on the
list so i think we could work through
that in the selection of the
administrator
representative emerit
thank you mr chair
in accounting there's a
kind of adage that fixed costs are
variable per unit
and variable costs are fixed per unit
what we're saying here is we're going to
establish a fixed cost for
administration which during the first
year
is going to be a real deal
during the second year not quite such a
good deal
during the third year
there's two cases let's say the first
year there's 300 cases fixed cost of
salary man amortizes great over 300
units
but when you get to year three and
you've got two cases and the same fixed
cost now those become extraordinarily
expensive
my question my thought process is an
arbitrator is a variable cost
can this part-time employee also be
compensated on a variable basis based on
so we we could set it up that way i mean
we we could have the person be
say a part-time or an employee within
the or a contractor reporting to the
judicial branch
who was paid you know on a variable
basis say according to the hours they
put in
i think as i think about it i think
you're right you know that this is a
better deal maybe in the early years not
my sense is is a full-time employee
it
it probably comes out in our favor if we
have to pay hourly for someone for
intense hours even in the first two or
three years that's that could be a lot
of money so i think we would save in the
beginning maybe not save on the back end
but it would it would balance out but i
do think it would be possible to if if
the determination by the committee is
you would rather have
this person be compensated sort of based
on work performed or this person and
whatever staff they had to utilize have
them be compensated based on work
performed i think we could set it up
that way i i think it's hard to predict
what would be an ult better deal for the
state financially
follow-up
yes
now my mine was not the hour of the of
the
administrator mine was
the case itself
the same range could apply a case that
has
i'm i'm winging it here you know these
has more than six variables for example
is valued at x
one that has two variables is valued at
0.5 x
so that the administrator is paid
on a fixed rate
based on the complexity of
the administration
not their hourly rate yep but that would
allow you to have multiple
administrators
if you have five people and three people
three of them are acceptable to
everybody you could now have three
administrators
on a part-time basis but a fixed
compensation schedule so it doesn't turn
into a kind of a runaway compensation
plan
just food for thought i'm okay yeah we
can certainly we can we can think about
that okay thank you yep
uh representative walsh
thank you um i would actually i just
have a request of the ag and that is um
can you find out if the court rules
permit
uh
what you're envisioning and that is that
we might have a mediator who continues
to take outside cases as appropriate in
their schedule and you know
obviously it would be helpful to the
committee to know
if this is what's possible under the
court rules and if it's not possible
under the court rules i'm wondering if
we need to add something in here
in the legislation that provides a
special exemption to make that possible
yes yeah we can absolutely find out
whether there's anything currently
within the court rules or even
statutes that apply to the court that
would prevent that and then if we
decided that that was a good idea we
could put language in to
to make an exception in this case
absolutely
uh okay so i now i have one um
so representative emmerich kind of
brought up a workload issue and i'm just
there's nothing in here about support
staff this administrator might need
or is there there there is yeah there
is
yeah there's permission for the
administrator to employ necessary
support staff and that or for the
i think they would also be temporary
employees of the judicial branch as
necessary that would be paid out of them
so that number can breathe if there's a
heavy volume the administrator can go
hire
people with the right skill set to
provide real contribution to helping
with the task yep okay and i think to
your point mr chairman that that is an
element of this that either even as how
we've drafted it would provide for some
variability so while you have an
administrator through the entire period
of time right their support staff may
rise and fall based on workload right i
all right so with that i'm going to move
to to number two um
this is a fairly simple change i think
found on page two lines 11-13
we just had some discussion at the last
work session about not wanting any part
of this to to be taken as
expanding or limiting the rights of
individuals under
under under state law or other parts of
state statute or state common law this
is meant to be
sort of a discrete
um
let's call it special process for this
particular class of
of claimants
and it's also not it any definitions in
here any concepts in here are not meant
to be modifying modifying the common law
or changing
some concept that may exist somewhere
i'm going to go ahead and tag you
representative lynn i i think this was
your point last time
i'm sorry not not completely because i'm
still very concerned about
the definition of sexual abuse
and including this rat this you know
removing coercion uh as a as part of the
statutory definition because i i'm
i'm very concerned about
what the basis for doing that is and if
it's not
i mean it's it would seem to me that
we're making
in the absence of some other body of law
we're making something
we're making a basis for the state to be
liable something that
is not does not currently provide a
basis of liability under the law and
that's
that that's what kind of concerns me
well so i
i think um
the case reference state foss i
that really gets to whether
the coercion requirement in order to to
convict of of the crime of
of sexual assault the variant of sexual
assault that is that um
that you have when it when you have a
person who has authority or power over
an individual using coercion
because we've used the criminal code to
define what what sexual assault is for
purposes of this you know civil claims
for which we'd pay damages that's why
we're carving that out
that rem i'm not sure that we're we're
removing what the state could be liable
for civilly even though someone maybe
hasn't committed
a crime if you're a corrections officer
who couldn't be convicted of a crime for
doing something i'm not sure
i mean i don't think i'm not aware of
cases that have tested that but i'm not
sure that
in a similar series of events
someone has had that interaction with
the corrections officer
maybe
that wasn't a criminal act there may
still be
based on the facts of that circumstance
and ability for someone to bring a civil
claim so i i'm not sure we're creating
we're necessarily creating new liability
for the state but that said i think
we're still dealing with the somewhat
different situation here because we're
dealing with with juveniles and so
saying
what we're really trying to say here is
that if someone is incarcerated
and they
have engaged in sexual acts consensually
with a guard
the fact that there was no
additional coercion other than the fact
that the person's incarcerated and the
person they've engaged in the acts with
as a guard
is not a reason to not consider that
sexual abuse for purposes of this
statute
the court at the end of the day in foss
was just interpreting what what the
state statute meant
not that i would say that i think the
court got it wrong but i think it would
be appropriate for the legislature to
say well okay for purposes of this we're
gonna we're not gonna go with how you've
interpreted
the statute i mean because the
legislature could always just make a
correction to the statute or change the
statute in response to that
in response to that that ruling so i
know i've kind of gotten not just to
your question are we creating new
liability but also the question that was
raised last time of whether this would
be appropriate
all right
matt
yeah i mean i guess the i guess my
concern is that
if if you if you were saying to us look
there's a well-established body of civil
law
that says that someone can be held
liable
for
this kind of sexual assault where
where there's no
where the requirements of the criminal
statute are not met i would have no
problem with that but it sounds like we
we don't really know what the answer to
that mean maybe they'll maybe a you know
the common law
means that and maybe it doesn't and so
my concern is
why would we
why would we say anything why wouldn't
we just say
you know
um
why wouldn't we just end the sentence
after the citation to the statute and if
it turns out that the civil law
of
you know aggravated of committing
aggravated uh
uh sexual assault does not require that
thing then then fine then you know that
i mean it does sort of seem like we're
changing
we're changing the substantive law
just for just for sort of this
this
you know these set of of plaintiffs and
that does bother me yeah it
and i will admit it it is there is a
slight discomfort to that
i think the reason
the reason from my perspective that it
that it makes sense in this situation
although i understand the arguments on
the other side is that
you know we've confronted this on the
criminal side there are certain acts
that that we can't charge for
um because of because of foss and
because of how the the court has
interpreted that statute
it doesn't necessarily mean on the civil
side that that we think those may not be
acts that that weren't appropriate that
that
could
um could give rise to a potential claim
we don't know but they could and since
part of this is a settlement mechanism
um i think i think there is an argument
that it's appropriate here because we're
doing other things in this legislation
that potentially
will result in payments by the state
that we wouldn't otherwise have to make
i mean i i imagine that there will be
claimants that come through this process
who if we litigated their claims would
be barred by limitations i'm almost
certain that would be the case and we
are setting that aside for purposes of
this so this is just one other
one other potential defense
save that we are
setting aside for purposes of this
process only
jen do you have anything to add to that
i want to make sure i'm hitting
everything
okay
i had a feeling even though i wasn't
even looking at her that she had
something to happen
justice lynn
i agree with you that the body of civil
law that defines the intentional tort of
assault is is completely separate from
how the criminal law
defines um the crime of aggravated
sexual assault or simple sexual assault
um
when we were thinking about the scope of
this legislation we thought about um how
to define the scope and because the
civil scope is so much broader and isn't
really applicable to activities that
happen within a detention facility we
opted to use the specific definitions in
the criminal code that apply to the
juvenile defense detention facility when
we looked at doing that we felt that
that law was just slightly too narrow
in that there is the coercion
requirement that has been
interpreted into the statute through the
foss case and
our understanding of of why that was uh
in the case law was because when you are
looking at putting someone
into jail for committing the crime of
sexual assault um it's important to have
the component be that
it's clear that that actor took an
intentional act and and that is done
through the prosecution having to
establish this element of coercion we
just felt that that was a little too
narrow and we wanted to broaden it just
a little by removing the coercion
element and and that's
the reason for the
the reference to the case law
the when we were here last time you
expressed a very important concern that
that not become
somehow engrafted into either the
criminal law or the civil law because
it's in this process and so the language
that we are proposing is to try to
clarify that
and and i don't know if that explanation
helps or not but that's how that wound
thank you i don't have any i i mean i
understand your position i'm still not
sure i agree with it but i understand it
okay
so so representative lynn
in your opinion
is this an issue that the legislature
should take a a different position on
than the one being recommended by the ag
i guess my my concern is this
is that this is going to be a statute in
other words i don't
i could completely understand that in
the context of a particular case
the administrator might say you know
well this was
the
under
under my interpretation of what the of
what the civil law would require
um the the somebody can be someone can
be liable and therefore the state should
have to pay uh
pay
uh even though there wasn't this
particular requirement of state versus
foss was met
and i but i guess i would think you
could do that
even if you didn't have that reference
and to put the to put the reference
in a statute
it seems to me that in in some sense
it you know it the legislature is now
sending a message that that this really
is what the civil law is
for all cases and i don't know that
that it may that it's appropriate to do
that in this kind of
legislation that that would be my basic
concern for why you shouldn't do it and
i'm not sure that that you need it i
mean i'm really not sure that you
couldn't accomplish what you want to
accomplish without with without saying
that
so that that's that's my concern
okay we we can think about it further
too and maybe even have an offline
conversation okay yeah all right i'm mr
chair
uh representative hatch thank you mr
we often do legislation in that
legislation we annotate not with
standing certain rsas
we're trying to
we often do legislation
that
does not
comply with certain rsas in miso state
notwithstanding rsa
whatever it may be
and
just if i may and i'm sorry to take the
time i need to understand the difference
what's happening here
with that i think that's kind of what
you're saying that's
this is not totally unique
do you understand the point
i i do kind of i don't i don't have a
coherent response i i don't think uh i
agree that it's yeah we do in certain
instances say sort of not withstanding
any other provision of law or
notwithstanding
x
this will apply for purposes of say this
section of the rsas i think this is a
little bit different because we're
referencing
case law which which is not common i
have not seen that before so so yeah i
think it's a similar concept to what
you'll see in other places in the
statute
this is though
unique so i think i do have to
acknowledge to justice lindsard
representative lin's point this is
unique
okay i think we're on bullet three
yep
so this is uh
this is a set of related but but
somewhat separate points um mostly just
to make sure we've got the incentives
for the incentives and and the integrity
of the process in the right place
so
the first change on bullet three you'll
see in page six lines
through 24-28
and this
is in direct response
to i'm forgetting who it was it might
have been representative emerick as
someone else who raised the point that
the claimant should know that by moving
to the resolution process the cap on
attorney's fees goes up
and so we just wanted to make clear
in the legislation
that the claimant has to have notice of
that that's got to be clear to the
claimant
this comes from some discussion i think
we had at the last work session and some
follow-up discussion after
regarding a concern
about the administrator potentially
knowing too much about the part the
attorney general and the claimant's
negotiations before the resolution
process and that
influencing the resolution process
and so
basically
what we want to make clear is that while
the ag designee and the claimant may
engage in settlement discussions based
on the initial filing of the claim and
the review
that those discussions will not be made
known to the administrator if
the claimant moves to a resolution
process
basically you don't want to end up with
a situation where whatever the attorney
general offers as a settlement just
becomes a floor in every resolution
process or that that influences the
administrator and i think the claimant
needs to
you know in order to
make put the incentives in the right
place the claimant needs to understand
that if they go through the resolution
process they could get less than what
the attorney general is offering or more
but
it's not guaranteed to be a minimum of
and then the last change here
just goes to
in the last draft we wanted to respond
to the point that some experts had made
which is that it's important for a
claimant to have an opportunity to meet
face-to-face with the administrator
we wanted to give the claimant that
opportunity but wanted to make clear
that that
that type of meeting alone
would not
result in in
the cap the cap going up on attorney's
fees it's not necessarily that's not
that doesn't mean they're necessarily
going to the resolution process they
just may feel like they want to be able
to say to the administrator that that
talk about what happened to them
um tell their story
so so is this the is this the best
section of your summary for us to uh
go off on the the side track of
the uh the the observation that was made
earlier today
saying that we need we we ought to let
the claimant get further in the process
and get to know the dollar amount before
they
realize that they've
they're now locked in
is this the right time to talk about
that i think so i think this would be a
the change that we made
in this draft it's actually a point
further down but given how the
discussion flowed with attorney
visananzo i think this is a good place
to talk about it
we made a change in this draft to
[Music]
to move the point at which a claimant
has to waive their right to go to court
from when they file a claim
to after they've had discussions with
the attorney general designee
and they decide to go to the resolution
process so the idea being that
you file your claim
the language attorney visananza was
referring to that he thought wasn't
clear is on page five
line three
where it says by filing a claim a
claimant waives their right to
simultaneously seek relief in court
what that is intended to accomplish is
to say if you file a claim
you're not giving up your right to go to
court but you are essentially agreeing
to stay any
lawsuit that you filed while you go
through this process so that we avoid a
situation where
now you're going through the process set
up by this bill you're litigating at the
same time
that doesn't just create a resource
problem i think it also creates
practical problems because we might be
engaging in discovery over here taking
depositions trading information and then
we're going through a separate process
at the same time it's just not it
it's not i think uh the ideal situation
it creates a number of problems so so i
think i get the simultaneous issue yep
um
the the the other part of what was being
said though and just because it's simple
to me is that
um they ought to the claimant ought to
know what the state is offering in a
dollar amount yep
before they lose their right to go back
to court
what what are your thoughts on the
timing of that
so my general thoughts on that are this
i mean it's not
a couple points one high level i think
the point was made and i think it's a
good one if
if we do that it removes i think
much of the purpose of this legislation
because all we've done is is
set up a much more complicated
mediation process than we would undergo
if we just tried to mediate this
so
i think it
it removes the purpose of the
legislation
overall
i also would say it's not the the
concept of
going through
an arbitration process as a exclusive
alternative to go to court
is not
an uncommon or or
strange concept i mean
this process is intended to be if you
elect the resolution process it's
intended to be
a kinder gentler simpler process by
which you are more likely to get
something
at the end of the day maybe less than if
you went to court but that's the
alternative you're electing
it's not it's meant to be an alternative
option it's not meant to be a
pre-litigation
mediation so
while i understand that
getting to wait and see what your reward
is before you have to waive your rights
to go to court
that would be
certainly positive for a claimant i
think it
it
it we've talked a lot about balance in
this trying to balance the rights of the
claimant balance our obligations to the
taxpayers balance the desire to provide
a
kinder gentler process while also
providing fair compensation i think
we're getting a little bit out of
balance if we
if we
if we do that
representative lynn yes you know and i
apologize mr chair i
i no
i'm honored to apologies
you here well no i just i have an issue
about an earlier point that that was
made about um
you mentioned and i think it's a very
good very good you know way that you've
drafted this on page six at the bottom
uh you note that the a.g and the
claimant may engage in discussions
um
uh
that that do not where the administ that
which they don't tell the administrator
about but the thing i'm concerned about
is
on page if you go back to page five in
line see
in section
eight c
it says um
once a claim is considered complete the
a.g designee will have 30 days to
indicate to the claimant and the and the
administrator
its position regarding the claim and so
i'm just concerned that
that may be
in other words does that
what
what is what is envisioned by that and
then also in in subsection d on the next
page it says following receipt
of the ag's position and i'm just
wondering i mean
that would tend to suggest unless there
was some different language that would
tend to suggest
that the administrator is going to be
aware of what
you know of what the ag sort of thinks
about the case and which would be
which may be inconsistent with the with
the administrator not knowing that yep
so i think and i'm gonna i'm gonna let
jen jump in on this too after i finish
because she and i talked extensively
about this but
there
there's a distinction between
the attorney general wanting to the
claim is gonna set out what happened
how much of the guidelines they think
that's worth
and
the attorney general has the opportunity
to look at that and give a position i
think
there's a distinction between the
attorney general maybe saying
yes there's sufficient evidence that
this hat we believe also there's say
sufficient evidence that this happened
or at least nothing to indicate this
didn't happen for
um let's say
allegation one through three
not sure there's sufficient evidence
that allegations four through five
there's something that would call into
question allegations four through five
part of the complaint
we would want the administrator to have
that
because
it's important for the administrator to
have kind of the general view
of the attorney general's general view
of the claim
that doesn't mean that the attorney
general designee and the claimant might
not then
as part of that conversation say okay
well
we have real questions about this you've
said x we've got questions about why
while we might be inclined to say
this to the administrator we would offer
you
an amount of money to to settle the case
and i think that's what we don't want
the administrator to have okay no i i i
see i i appreciate your clarification
and i understand what you're saying okay
how'd i do
yep
i don't have anything to add to that
specifically the only other thing i
would add is that i think this also goes
to the plaintiff's council's concern
that the
plaintiff needs to understand the
state's position before it exercises the
waiver by having the attorney general's
designee weigh in on which parts of the
claim analogous to an answer in
litigation which parts of the of the of
the claim the attorney general believes
should be paid that that is the state's
kind of first offer
and then the
claimant would be asked to make the
choice whether based on that offer they
want to now leave the process and go to
litigation or that whether they want to
move forward through the resolution
process with the administrator
that the decision
at that point would be between two
different processes
if they don't like the state's offer but
they would have the information that i
think council is looking for
for that to be an informed decision
mr may i
just follow up with one point
you know i'm just wondering and again i
i understand what what you've said and
that may that may the way you have it
may be fine given what you've said but
i'm just wondering
if
you wouldn't be able to accomplish what
you want to accomplish
without
without getting
the administrative without giving the
administrator knowledge that might you
know sort of
intentionally or unintentionally cause
them to cabin in what the value is going
to be if in section c
you simply said um
the ag will have uh
30 days to indicate
right now it says to to claim it and the
administrator what if you just said
we'll have 30 days to
uh to indicate to claim it
uh its position regarding the claim and
then in d
if you said
you know following um
uh
receipt by the administrator
of uh an indication that the ag has has
informed the claimant of its position
you know then certain things will happen
that way the the administrator wouldn't
have the information
really at you know sort of at all about
what the ag's position is until
after the you know you you you and the
the the the ag's designee and the admin
and the uh claimant have not been able
to come to an agreement then you would
provide
then you'd go to the administrator to
have the administrator resolve it
just
we certainly could structure it that way
but i think as a practical matter as
as soon as
the claimant were to make the election
to go to the administrator we would
still want to then provide the
administrator with our position anyway
as a starting point for moving forward i
i didn't envision that the ag designee
would ever back off of a position going
into a resolution proceeding that they
had told the claimant
was what they would resolve the claim
for what they thought it was worth okay
all right thank you uh all right
so i i just want to let you know you're
not doing very well managing your 45
minutes
all right let's see if we can make up
time all right
yeah
um so moving to number four
uh further clarification and improvement
regarding installment payments
we've discussed this a little bit and mr
early discussed this a little bit but
after having uh consulted with with um
with some folks that i think it was
representative walt suggest we consult
with we thought it was a good idea
um coming out of the discussion last
time when we talked about the option for
a claimant to take their
take any award in installment payments
to add a third option we started with
two options one was lump sum one was the
state pays out the claim in installment
payments of up to 10 years
we added a third option which is
the claimant can essentially elect that
their let's just call 250 000 award be
used to purchase an annuity from a
company and so it'll be that company
that they purchased it from that pays
out the claim that also gives more
flexibility that that annuity could not
might not be ten years it might be more
but it it's an additional option for the
claimant that doesn't really change the
hit to the state because it's not really
any different than the state paying it
all in a lump sum to the claimant in
this case the claimant's using that lump
sum
to structure something with a third
party that
provides a little more flexibility
so does the state end up making a
recommendation on on which settlement
route they go or or who they might use
if they want a structured settlement it
we do provide in here that the the
administrator will maintain a list of
of companies you could use for this
purpose right but we have removed the
provision based on concern we had last
time that the administrator could impose
installment payments over the claimant's
injection and so is that list off of
some
vendor
list that already exists or or is there
do you imagine a process of where you
would
bar somebody from being on that list
i think it it discretioned the
administrator the language says the
administrator may maintain that list i
think it would be up to the
administrator in consultation with
whoever they think is appropriate to to
have a list of recommendations certainly
doesn't mean that the the claimant has
to take someone from that list just it
so number five i know we've already had
some discussion on this but this change
came out
of the discussion at the last work
session
regarding how important these guidelines
are going to be
we've added provisions that would
provide that after
the attorney general and claimants
counsel
meet to figure out what the claims
process and guidelines will look like
that that has to be approved by the
fiscal committee
the reason for that i think is that
the guidelines
however they look are going to be very
important in determining how how and
where claims land between zero dollars
and whatever the cap is
the guidelines are going to be very
important in determining really at the
end of the day how much money
may go out the door and so i think there
i detected last time a discomfort from
this committee with just delegating that
out to the attorney general and
claimants council and having it never
come back before before elected
representatives and so the idea here is
that
claimants counsel
and the attorney general
would meet
and agree on on a set of process and
guidelines that would be presented to
the fiscal committee and the fiscal
committee could either approve or the
fiscal committee could object and
articulate concerns which would require
claimants counts on the attorney general
to bring back a revised proposal
for approval
so that that is was our attempt to
address
i think what was a desire to have
have a last check
by by legislative representatives
on these guidelines i understand and i
think at this point i'll address
attorney visananzo's concern i
understand the concern that
that provides sort of another point at
which there could be disagreement or the
process could go off the rails
i think we have to balance that concern
with the competing
uh consideration that to the point you
made representative edwards this is
taxpayer money
and
you know with without some form of
approval of these guidelines there's a
lot of delegation being given
to
to determine how much money is going out
the door to just the attorney general
and claimant's counsel so i think this
is ultimately a determination for for
this committee given that you are the
legislature so you can represent the
legislature's interests i generally
think that's a good idea i mean it's
something we would recommend
but it
again you know like all of this it's a
determination you have to make in
balancing those considerations
i i have confidence that we could work
with claimants counsel to come up with
something and then make a very good
presentation to the fiscal committee
so i don't have the same consternation
over the process as attorney visanzo
does
representative walsh thank you mr
chairman uh mr attorney general are you
aware of any other time in the state
where the legislature weighs in
on the settlement terms of a civil
action involving the state i mean this
i've
been here 14 years but i am unaware of
anything but that certainly there's a
lot of things i don't know and i'm
wondering if this is a unique animal or
if there's another occasion where the
legislature gets a say in those kinds of
things
yeah great question thank you
representative so the concept is not
foreign because i i think it's rsa 1435
forgetting exactly the citation
provides a 1435 e for any settlement
over i think it's one quarter of one
percent
of of the last fiscal year's total
revenue
the the legislature would have to
approve that settlement i think that
number is around 4.6 million dollars
so
let's take a separate case from this i
could not go out and settle a case
with another claimant for something else
for five million dollars without having
it be approved by the full legislature
but through through an actual act of
legislation so this concept is somewhat
similar to that given how much money
we're talking about here but we would
this would be a simpler approval
mechanism because it would just be the
fiscal committee as opposed to bringing
this back these guidelines back as a
bill now this is a little different
because
in this case the fiscal committee would
not be approving say just a dollar
amount or terms the fiscal committee
would be approving
sort of a piece of this settlement
process but i think while it's a little
bit different it's a concept that the
legislature has contemplated before
because that's built into 1435e
yep
could you while we're talking many could
you address um another couple of points
uh one is uh there's concern that for uh
physical abuse only 150 cap would be uh
arbitrarily low
if you could address that um and then
given that we since we've last met we we
have expanded the scope a little bit of
what we're going to cover
uh and i'm just curious if it's your
position that 100 million is going to be
adequate
yes thank you for that so i i think
i think there's a couple different
points in there so the first one i'm
going to take is
expanding this to include physical abuse
claims and so i'm going to skip ahead to
a bullet that's on our list
we
over the course of these discussions i
think we've talked a lot about that
whether this should just be this should
just cover sexual abuse claims or
whether it should be broadened to
include physical abuse claims
i think as we've thought about it we've
really wrestled with it as you know my
position has been that this should just
cover sexual abuse claims given the
physical abuse claims whether there
might have been a reason for those
claims then the need to see records to
determine whether those claims happened
i think or whether the events
that underlie those claims happen
i think as we've thought about it
we can
resolve those the concerns with the
difficulty of verifying physical abuse
claims and the difficulty of parsing
through potential defenses by including
them within what's covered here
but accounting for the potential
difficulties and verifying them with a
lower cap on what we'd pay out
it's all about i think balancing what i
what i see as a desire on the part of
the state and on the legislature to
compensate claimants for harm they've
suffered but balance that with verifying
whether
alleged acts have occurred and also
accounting for what the state's exposure
would be if we went to court because at
the end of the day this is taxpayer
money and so we
i would struggle with the idea of paying
paying an amount for claims it's a lot
more when they're worth
so that in trying to balance all of that
i think we feel that including physical
abuse claims in the scope of this but
with a lower cap
is a good place to balance that
the second point well
and it's also the case that
if um if there's a claimant that
believes the 150
k cap is too low
they have the ordinary processes that
they can leverage yes if a claimant
believes that that cap is too low they
can they can go to court um i want to
address
a point that that came up in the earlier
discussion which was the caps themselves
150 000 and i think 1.5 million
and they were described as arbitrary
i just want to respectfully disagree
with that i think as we have
stated in past work sessions we we've
done
a lot of verdict research to come up to
first come up with the 1.5 million
dollar cap we've provided that to this
committee
we think based on those numbers 1.5
million is important because or is is
appropriate because with that cap
this process
can be designed in a way where the
claims that are paid out
sort of fit roughly with the national
average these types of cases
the hundred and fifty thousand dollar
cap
is based on looking at physical abuse
claims within the verdict research we've
the rough average there
it's it's lower i think it falls
60 between 65 000 and 75 000 and so
that's how we determined a 150 000 cap
so while i would fully acknowledge that
someone may disagree with the research
we've done or think other cases should
be included in that research
i i do not think it's fair to describe
those caps as arbitrary i think they're
based on verdict research the other
point i want to address is this
there was a reference to other caps that
the legislature has already established
the cat the cap in 4 14 35 e
and the cap in
i'm forgetting the sight but the 325 000
cap
um i think it's in 541.
the 1435 ecap
is a settlement authority cap that is
meant to limit what the attorney general
can do with regard to settling cases
without coming back to the legislature
for approval
based on the formula that's about 4.6
million dollars so i think that that cap
is not the same as the type of cap we're
talking about here
which is or the type of caps we're
talking about here which are caps that
we've determined based on what we think
would be fair amounts given
what these types of cases have settled
for in the past
the 325 thousand dollar cap
that's also not a a
cap that's meant to to value a
particular claim
that is what i'll describe as a
sovereign immunity cap it basically says
that the state is only
um that you can only get up to 325
thousand dollars
per incident for for various claims
against the state
but that that's a general
cap for that could cover anything
it
it's not the same as the type of cap
again we're talking about here which is
for a specific type of claim that we've
been able to do research on so i think
you know that
while i i understand that claimant's
counsel may think that 150 000 is too
low and 1.5 million dollars is too low
i would submit to you that what we would
need to see to determine to assess that
is
other research or additional research
regarding what types of payouts have
happened in these types of cases
i don't think the numbers we should be
looking to to determine whether those
are too low
are
the cap provided ford 1435e and the 325
thousand dollar cap provided for in 541.
i think those are different
numbers that have been established for
different purposes and they don't really
fit with what we're talking about here
so that that's how i would respond
okay so about two weeks ago i i
understood that you all were open
to having uh independent research
provided to you
should the 1.5 million ceiling be
challenged did you did you ever receive
any
independent research to challenge no no
we have not received that to this point
so representative you have a question
thank you mr chairman uh general
furmella while you were doing your
research
has any work been done
to show
these settlements have improved the
person's feelings or their life or
anything has anyone looked into that or
has
they've gone on as miserable as ever and
and
so it's a fair question representative i
mean i'll start by answering that as no
we have not done that level of research
i i think that's because what we're
what an appropriate number is
um to account for what the state's
exposure is if we go to court
and to account for
or to determine how you just value these
cases generally from a damages
perspective
it would be very hard for us to do
general research on whether
someone who has suffered terrible acts
of abuse whether the money helped them
how much good it did them
i think that that's a really case by
case fact-specific inquiry that's
difficult to conduct because i don't
think there's a lot of folks who are
then tracking people who receive these
these monies and and tracking how well
or how how much of a positive impact
that money had for them i think it's
fair to say that many who have suffered
sort of terrible acts or incidents of
abuse
we've talked about this before no amount
of money is ever going to fix that well
so it's hard to measure the positive
impact that the money has what we're
really trying to determine is
what are those cases worth what what
what are the damages that flow from that
we're finance we like to see results
okay and to carry on with that just a
little bit further i
i think i took a business law class in
and
the history seemed to be that it was
generally accepted
for
decades if not hundreds of years that
financial compensation
was the primary way in which you tried
to make somebody whole
i mean if you can't if you can't go back
and remediate the harm
then the financial compensation for
damages
is is just the standard and common way
that we do this in society is that fair
i think that's fair and i think the
reason is is because it that it i think
we have historically struggled in many
cases to come up with a better way of
remedying harm than just to pay
financial damages
there are times when we when we do but
the more straightforward way
is is financial compensation
thank you uh representative mooney
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question perhaps it's been
said and i missed it do we have any idea
what the total amount of individuals
housed at the detention center is from
its founding
so i i don't know the answer to that
question i think it's something we could
determine i mean it's it's a fairly
large number but i don't have that
number
for you i i've listened to mr lipman
before and they they have stats on all
of that so i think i think to jump in
and answer the question uh it can be
determined they have the records to do
that
would you like that done should we send
a request to mr lipman to pull that
together
thank you mr chairman i think so only
because uh this is just an attempt to
sort of sharpen the focus as to
what we're talking about in terms of
numbers we've heard multiple times that
there are between four 500 alleged
victims i think it would be helpful to
the committee to know how what
percentage of the full residency that
would be
okay because i'm going to ask mr ripple
to send the email to mr lipman so just
to make sure we clarify exactly what
you're asking
you want the total population that's
ever gone through ydc
from the
from patient one to
resident one to
when to today or to the beginning or
beginning of 2022 what's what's your
range
uh the beginning of 2022 would be fine
okay do you have that mr ripple
thank you
thank you mr chairman
i
yeah if the same resident had been
incarcerated more than once i suspect
that the number that we were asking
the way it just got phrased would
include some some repeat offenders so if
somebody was there three times that
would be three i i i don't know i don't
know how
good mr lipman has a database to screen
that out but
but i think in each of those uh
incarcerations represents a chance for
um
violation so i i
although the number could be padded in a
sense i i think it still gets at the
kind of
scope that representative mooney's
looking for is it i don't want to speak
for you though
if you don't mind mr chairman uh it
sounds like that may be two categories
of counting i was referring to
individuals uh it sounds like
representative long may be referring to
those that have been
sentenced there or placed there
so
sounds like we may be getting into two
categories my original thought was
individuals how many individuals
were talking
so you're looking for unique individuals
if they've been in there three times
then you still just want to see them
reflected as one
correct
all right i i think mr ripple can ask
for that i just don't know how great
their database is to help go through
that sort of a sort
so
so we'll just we'll try to get the best
data we can from them
representative walls
thank you i'm just going to suggest we
give poor mr ripple a start date i don't
know how long
it's been there but but for example
anything before 1940 i can't imagine is
going to be relevant because i can't
imagine those victims might still be
alive and and from the infinity and time
i'm just suggesting we come up with a
reasonable start date
that that's a great request and i've i
fudged that by knowing that we gave up
on the 1980 start date and we can go
back further i don't know when we first
opened up a ydc though
but your point is valid you know the
people would have could have aged out or
or passed away
so representative or excuse me
attorney ramsey may i weigh in please so
i think
uh
a way to make this not quite so
monumental a task for the department
would maybe be to start by asking them
um what they have available to them
through their electronic records i do
think that there is um the ability to
run a search back to a certain point of
time and then they would have to start
looking at handwritten records and 1940
would be a predecessor facility um that
moved in and out of agencies that no
longer exist and had a board of trustees
and i think
theoretically it might be possible but
it would be an enormous amount of work
for the department to go all the way
back so i don't know if that would
answer your question representative
mooney but i do think the department
could fairly quickly give you a number
of what they maintain electronically and
all right so i think she's agreeable to
that and then so obviously if if if we
limit it to electronic records
then we just want to know when the the
date begins so that we can under
interpret the data
representative burger yes um
whatever they are the plaintiff's
lawyers have indicated they're 500
people
so maybe they could tell us
the
earliest date
that would in that would then
give us perhaps an idea
of where to start
rather than trying to pull something
yeah
i i i i don't know if we should ask you
something like that but do you want to
okay
so i still think we're we may end up
being high-centered around the idea of
what's in the electronic records um but
we we now know that if it went back to
1963 that would
i heard him say 63. yeah
okay
all right and my hearing's not so good
all right so
um
i think
i think we i think we've gone on but you
never answered the question about is a
hundred million dollars going to cover
this yeah and i know i've been asked
that before and i know my answer before
has been it
it depends you know
it just is
hard to predict how many
victims will eventually come through
what amount they're gonna get based on
what we see regarding their allegations
what we see when we look at it and give
our position
um
it's also going to depend on where the
guidelines
land
so is 100 million dollars enough i think
there is a reasonable possibility that
it will not be enough at the end of the
day
it's hard to know that
now i
and it will probably be a couple years
or at least a year you know one or two
years before we have a
sense to see kind of where this is going
so so i understand that answer i i the
the basis of my question was that uh
we've expanded the scope of who might be
covered and the incremental expansion of
scope i'm just curious and i don't need
it now but
it'd be interesting to know how the
scope expansion is going to affect the
pot what i can say on that so
what i can say on that is this first you
know we've expanded the scope but the
cap is a lot lower but second
based on discussions we've had and i
won't i don't want to go into details on
this and i can't make guarantees based
on this
but based on discussions we've had with
plaintiff's council over over months
my understanding of the value of these
claims is that
adding physical abuse only
adding the folks that say have physical
abuse only claims would not
we're not talking a magnitude of
doubling or tripling the state's
exposure you know it's it's a
it's a percentage that that i don't view
as
uh
extremely significant
in the scheme of the amount of money
we're talking about i know that's very
vague but it's i just can't give you
exact numbers
but
part of the reason we've recommended
this and recommended a lower cap is that
if these are the values
that you set these are the caps that you
set based on my understanding of who the
the very high level understanding of who
the physical abuse only claimants are i
don't think we're talking about a major
major expansion of the exposure to the
state but that will depend on where
these caps end up
thank you
are you ready for point six
yes
point six page seven uh lines eight
through ten
this was just to clarify
that
claims will be processed in the order
that they are received as complete not
just in the order that they are received
to address the concern that someone
might rush to get an incomplete claim in
to get to the front of the line
take a while to make their claim
complete and then they're at the front
of the line you don't get your place in
line until your
point seven is on page eight lines
thirty three through thirty four this
just represents uh chairman of
chairwoman umberger's point that there
should be more frequent reporting to the
fiscal committee the original draft had
annual reporting we changed that to be
quarterly
i think we have already talked about 0.8
which was a expansion of the scope to
include claims of physical abuse
so
the one additional point i'll just add
on that concept is that
as part of the expansion of the scope
we have also
revised the factors that
the administrator would or that the
guidelines would consider to account for
the additional challenges of evaluating
physical abuse claims so for instance
those factors
include
you know
how long ago
the events took place whether there were
records available that corroborate
corroborate the events or the
allegations those are the type of
factors we think we should include if
we're going to include physical abuse
claims because that
that accounts for some of the
difficulties in evaluating those claims
and whether there are defenses and
so 0.9 is just
some more technical changes that were
made to to account for some of the other
process changes we've made that we've
already discussed but
for instance because we are now
suggesting that the administrator be
appointed after the guidelines are
approved we've just had to push back
the notice
the notice deadline for instance so that
has moved i think from october to
december
um
you know that that's a little bit of a
guess right as to what an appropriate
deadline is to get all that stuff done
to get the notice out and start the
process but
we have december
in here the reason i think we can be a
little bit ambitious with that deadline
is that
even though the administrator it won't
officially be appointed until the
guidelines are established it doesn't
mean that we couldn't be working in
parallel on the tasks of negotiating the
claims process and guidelines and also
talking about potential administrator
candidates for us to submit to the
supreme court so the hope would be is
that we work out the guidelines we get
them approved by fiscal
and very soon after we're ready to
submit a list to the supreme court
who
i i
i think we can be we can be confident
the court will
will be helpful to us in acting on that
quickly so that that's where the kind of
the december first date comes from we
could always move that back but i think
my experience is giving everyone a
ambitious deadline to work to that's not
too ambitious will keep things moving
along
so we we heard testimony that suggested
that
we've got the order wrong that we should
hire the administrator before we come up
with the claims matrix
what are what are your thoughts on that
specific
observation yep so i think one of the
primary points there from attorney
vicinanzo was that
the administrator could be helpful
perhaps in in mediating that discussion
between claimants counsel and the
attorney general's office on what those
while i see that point
i think there's also an argument to be
made and i lean towards this argument
that the administrator who is going to
be the ultimate
judge that makes determinations on what
a what an award should be
shouldn't necessarily be involved in
writing the
the law if you will that they're gonna
be applying right you know we don't have
judges
draft the laws they're gonna apply i
think i think
working out the guidelines and then
handing them to the administrator and
saying
here's essentially the law you're
operating on different purposes of this
this is what you will be applying
i think there's a pretty strong argument
that there's more integrity to that
process that said i
i think from our perspective we're open
we're open to thinking about that
differently but that's why we have we
have recommended
for now setting it up in that order
so so i have a two two part question
one is um
should we get some experience with this
and we think that the ranges just were
wrong for a category or multiple
categories
is there a process or what what would we
do in order to
relook
the claims matrix to see if it's you
know needs to be tweaked
so the process that this draft provides
for is that it it the matrix can be
tweaked by agreement of claimants
counsel and the ag but by coming back to
the fiscal committee for approval of any
revisions okay and then the second
question is
you guys are putting so much work into
this is there benefit of having the
administrator on board
a little early anyways to help relieve
the administrative workload of the ag's
so i would say
yes there's always benefit to relieving
the administrative burden i do think a
lot of the work that will happen
prior to the administrator coming on is
is negotiation it's really the
negotiation regarding
what the process and guidelines look
like when the administrator comes on
it's their job to take that and
implement it
i
i'm not sure the administrator can
relieve us of the work we would be doing
aside from them the work they're going
to be doing doesn't really overlap with
the work that we'll be doing before they
so just to challenge that idea so you'll
be sending out the public uh or the
press releases to all the different
media that we've talked about before
before the administrator gets there no i
think the administrator is responsible
for that so the administrator once
they're on board they're responsible for
putting out all the notices and
yeah
all right so is there any value in front
loading that so that you know we
well i think it
again it depends because if i think
the notice really shouldn't go out until
the guidelines have been adopted because
part of the importance of the guidelines
is that that gives notice to these
potential claimants of what they're
signing up for if they decide to come
through this process and i i think that
addresses a concern that's been raised
at the end of the day
this is intended to be an alternative
option to traditional litigation so
we want
claimants to have ample advance notice
of what this looks like before they even
start to think about signing up
because they don't have to sign up for
this and if an individual claimant
thinks it isn't fair or it's not enough
or it's not going to provide enough
relief they can go through the
litigation
all right so that i think brings us to
point
which we have talked about
uh but
the this this we discussed it previously
so i'll just hit it quickly
this is the change where we have moved
to the point at which a claimant has to
waive their right to go to court from
the filing of the claim
to
the moment where they have to decide
whether to take whatever they've been
offered by the attorney general or go to
the resolution process under this draft
if you decide to go to a resolution
process with the administrator
at that point you're waiving your right
to go to
court so that that's that change
and then point 11
we just put it on here we we haven't put
sunset language in here yet but it's on
our list to do it just is we need to
know
kind of we need to be close to the final
place of what provisions this will
contain before we can say which
provisions need to sunset and which
do you have any alibis you got things
that you want to add to that i'm sorry
military term um
uh do you have any additional comments
that are not on your summary
or that
previous testimony raised some issues
that you weren't prepared beforehand to
deal with is there any you got any
strays
yeah i'll hit a couple just on the right
to know concerns and i know miss timmons
is going to take a look at that summary
and bring it back
i just want to reiterate that you know
we
what we're trying
let me say this transparency i think in
this process is very important but what
we're trying to do is balance the need
for transparency
with i think the need to have
at least the option for privacy for
victims who might come through this
process and this is a a pretty unique
process that we're setting up
and it's why i've said before and i
would i would say it now i don't think
the 91a just process of
balancing the privacy interests with
with the interests of the public
is a good
mechanism to apply to this process
because part of making a victim
comfortable with going through this
process is some level of certainty on
how much privacy they're going to be
entitled to
so i i would be uncomfortable with just
relying on 91a if there are additional
tweaks to the language that we have here
or the exemption that we put in here
that someone wants to recommend i think
there's room for that but i just wanted
to hit that that i think not relying on
then i'll just run through
i think i've hit a lot of the points
that were provided in a claimant's
yeah i think i've covered everything
that i wanted to cover i'll just uh
look to attorney ramsey in case there's
at the last work session there was a
question
asking us to look into whether there was
any sort of a national database that we
could look to
to identify
potential claimants that might be in
other
state facilities
i have looked into that and wanted to
let you know
that we've not identified any kind of a
database
like is requested
the only thing that
we could identify that might be able to
be used is there is a professional
association of administrators uh well of
corrections of
uh
officers and there is a directory that
that organization publishes it would be
possible that the administrator could um
reach out to the
the leaders of other states facilities
and and just request as an accommodation
that they circulate the word within
their facilities but we did not find any
way to
identify
by individual a mailing address if you
will and send a letter directly to that
individual
i i forget who asked that question i
think that was you represented walls
does that do it still seems like there's
a an
avenue to try to find people who may be
incarcerated in other states is do you
understand where we're at are you okay
with that i do you know it is what it is
if it doesn't exist i mean i asked if
there's a national database the answer
apparently is no if that's the case
i commend them for coming up with
another alternative and that is to try
and find a way to reach out to those
facilities and publish the uh
oh all right um anything else
attorney ramsey uh we i got
representative lynn
i had just just one question on on
uh section 10 on the bottom of page
seven over on to eight um
the
am i corr am i correct in understanding
that the last sentence of that section
which says the conduct of such a meeting
shall not be considered part of the
resolution process and shall not be
available
if a resolution process is requested
until after it is completed in my
understanding that that means
that that that meeting shall not occur
until after the administrator has
rendered a decision
yes and that was to address the concern
that you know sort of that private
moment with the judge right right and
suddenly suddenly the value of the claim
goes up or whatever yeah okay that's
fine
okay okay so
so um i just want to walk through the
timeline and and i mr well go ahead
representative walls before i do that
thank you i think before you get into
the housekeeping there's something i
want to say as i'm sitting here
listening to all this and looking at the
latest of this is best i can look at it
kind of on the fly
this process is only going to work if
the plaintiffs buy in
and the plaintiff's attorneys have i
know been trying to work with you to
create a process that they think their
clients are going to buy into
and i'm going to go somewhere that i've
never gone before in the legislature and
that's actually to a hollywood movie
and that is
on last friday i i did the
bar review uh my cles and one of them
was ken feinberg i don't know if either
of you were uh watch that
um and at the beginning of of his cla
ken feinberg for those of you who don't
recall was the mediator who settled all
of the 911 cases and it's done quite a
few since then but he's best known for
the 9 11 cases
take this down for a minute anyway he
announced that the movie worth that both
he and his kids and his if his kids are
like my elbow on netflix if you have
netflix but it was really interesting
because a lot of what the movie focused
on was sort of the evolution of mr
feinberg and his staff and understanding
the needs of the victims and sort of
bending a bit of their process to meet
the needs of the victims
and trying to get the victims to sign on
and they had set a goal that they had to
have 80 percent of the victims sign on
or they thought that it wouldn't work
and they're sitting there the day before
the deadline and they got 55 percent of
the victims
and of course there's this dramatic end
where they do some of the correct moves
and make some of the correct
considerations so they end up with 97 of
the victims signed on to that process
but it was an evolution over two years
that you sort of see in that movie of
how everybody on both sides got there
how they got there to meet the needs of
the victims and how the victims got
there to realize that this really was a
fair settlement
and it was i bring that up because
that's really what we're trying to do
here we're trying to find that sweet
spot where
it limits the exposure of the state and
where it also provides a system where
the victims are going to say yes this is
a process that works for me
and there's a couple of things in here
that concern me that we're not going to
get the victims to sign on to this
you know we started with a ver a more um
uh trauma-informed process
i think we are moving away from that to
some extent
i think the change in the language about
whether the victims there's a
presumption the victims are to be
believed is part of that and that
concerns me
and and i guess i just wanted to say
this to say let's keep in mind what
we're trying to do here we're trying to
set up a process that the victims are
going to buy into
and that's not easy to do i'm not naive
about that and and so i'm just trying to
encourage everybody here to get to that
point because i think it's in
everybody's interest to have a system
that the victims will buy into because
every lawyer in this room and probably a
lot of other people know litigation is
never a great way to go it's just not
it's really hard on everybody it's
expensive it's emotionally draining it's
just tough and we have the potential
here to come up with a system that
doesn't re-victimize these victims by
making them go through the litigation so
i guess what i really wanted to say is
let's keep in mind this process of what
we're trying to do we're trying to get
to something that is protective of the
state and and the state's exposure but
also is something that the victims
are actually going to be willing to
accept because i'm not sure we're there
yet
you're free to respond if you'd like
yep no i mean i i'll start by just
saying this i i absolutely agree that
you know that this is tough and and we
really want to get to a place where
where as many victims as possible will
participate
i also think that
we we should keep in mind that
we probably will never get to a place
where every single victim will
participate
and
i
we also won't this is one step in kind
of i think as this bill is setting out a
process that will play out even after
the bill is passed it will depend on
what the guidelines look like what the
process looks like
so
it's going to be hard to
to guarantee participation the last
point i'll make is this and there's no
way to make this point without sounding
a little cold and i don't mean it this
way but
we want the victims to participate
but i think
i as attorney general at least have a
responsibility
not to
have that become so dominant of a
consideration that we pay out more money
than is fair because i think at the end
of the day
there's no question that the more money
that's available the more attractive
this process will be and we want this
process to be fair and attractive enough
that it provides a good option but
not so attractive that it is
we're simply paying more than the state
really should be paying when you look at
what these claims would be valued at
based on past settlements based on what
the state ex states exposure is in
litigation at least that as the state's
attorney i think i have to express that
view ultimately there are policy
considerations that that the committee
i think can take
uh can take into consideration that
might lead you to a different conclusion
but i just felt it was important to
express i think where where we come from
as the attorney general's office it's
balancing i think the desire that
representative waltz articulated and
also balancing i think what is our
obligation to to not recommend that the
state do something more than we think it
really should do based on the risk
again we can make that recommendation
then the committee can decide to do
something different but i think our
recommendation needs to stay consistent
with that that duty that i have
all right thank you uh any
further questions or comments from the
committee members
do we do is there anyone out in the
audience that uh
feels compelled to speak up we're
closing in on the end here
um i'm not seeing anyone so so i'm gonna
i'm gonna ramble a little bit and this
is for mr hoffman mr ripple
representative umberger and of course
the ag's office
where we're where i think we are
is that um
if we look at uh tuesday
um march 1st it's really like right upon
us
is there any rational way in which we
can take all of the feedback that you've
gotten today
turn it into
you know version three of the ag's world
um
and then
miss ripple mr hoffman i i i think this
the thing that we vote on
needs to come through ols doesn't i
we're not going through ols now as as
we're in the work process but but what
we vote on needs to go be a
ols validated right so i'm seeing a yes
on that
so
is this are we even in the
area of the doable with that kind of a
timeline given that um the claims
attorney wants to
take some time to think about the
appointment of the administrator
can can we get that done representative
umberger what do you think um what
what i would recommend is that uh
kevin take what we have here to ols
okay and get up
and get us
a draft from ols
for
tues tuesday whatever whatever day it is
and i'm
i'm sure they can turn that around
without without a problem this is not a
heavy
time for them
and then
all of us know
at this point what's in here
so if
people have recommended changes
then they need to come to us and say
on
line 25
page six
this is my recommendation for new
wording
and then we can turn that around
and not and not come in and say well i
don't i don't agree
if we don't have something
to replace what
you know what's currently here we can go
on until june
and never get
resolution
so it just i guess that i'm i'm just
saying that you know
the ag will
make the recommended changes and he'll
come back
you know kind of like you did and say
you know page four we need to
make these changes and
if um
the uh
plaintiff's attorney comes in he needs
to say this is what
the language i want for
choosing the our uh administrator
because otherwise we're going to be in
this
and then i think at that point
we can either
uh
either say
you know
how many of you agree with what
the attorney general has in that area
how many of you agree with the changes
that have been recommended by
you know joe jones
all right okay so it so it'll i
hopefully
it will
you know speed up the process there's no
doubt that we're going to have to have
another meeting right
so the first
so as you
two were taking notes
is did you did you take any notes that
tells you that you want to go to version
three or or did you just confirm that
version two
so i'll let jen weigh in on this too my
sense is we wouldn't have a lot
we'd have some pretty minor changes
coming out of this at least
for now that we would recommend so i
don't i don't see a lot of robust
changes for a version three um
so i think what
we could do one of two things to be
helpful on tuesday we could either
bring another revision or
we could bring
we could come with
any changes we have kind of a list
instead so that
and that
it's kind of what i know happens
sometimes in the process there's a vote
on a change without seeing the exact
language and then okay we approve that
change
go do language we could come with a list
like that because if you're going to
send something to ols today
and have that in front of you on tuesday
it might be confusing for us then to
have another red line as opposed to a
sheet of what i would imagine would be
if any changes for the purposes of
tuesday
fairly minor i i think i'd like to go a
third way okay
and and and i'm i'm trying to respect my
chairman's
feedback and what what i think i heard
you say that makes sense though is let's
let's get what we can over to ols
immediately
under the belief that we're we're really
getting close
okay and that gives ols an opportunity
to create a document for us on tuesday
that this group
can
choose to move potentially to the
finance committee
i'd like to get that document
so we can at least say yes or no to a
specific approved document is that is
that
with with whatever changes they might
sure people could still come back to us
right
on tuesday but but can you
given the lateness of the day and the
fact that it's uh predicted that we're
going to do another snowmageddon
tomorrow that can can we get something
to uh
or is this coming to you kevin or to to
mike
to go to ols
who's who's gonna com
okay can you can you get sort of um what
you think is a thumbs up
to to to us and specifically to mr
ripple so he can get ols cranked because
i'd like i'd like a formal document
tuesday
sure
okay yeah i think what we
i think any changes we'd have at this
point we could do
fast and so we we would get yeah we
could get that to ols quickly i think in
time for them to turn it around by
tuesday all right yeah or send it to
kevin and then kevin can yeah yeah
representative
yeah thank you mr chairman you know what
the only the only question that i had
and i may be misinterpreting attorney
vicinanzo but
it sounded to me like
many of the things that we have sort of
um that we have talked about and that
you've talked about
are things that it may be that that you
know he would end up being able to agree
with the one thing that i that
it seemed to me and if you know correct
me i guess i'd say correct me if i'm
wrong the one thing that that it seemed
like was a big a big point that he
objected to strenuously and we
and i guess i'm just wondering have we
sort of
at least tentatively kind of uh
taken a position as as a committee on
this is the issue of whether the the
the basis of liability should be
extended beyond
sexual abuse and physical abuse to other
things um because that seemed to me to
be a big point of his which we which we
haven't focused on i'm i mean just
speaking personally i'm perfectly
content with leaving it exactly where it
is but um
but you know i don't know how everybody
else feels about that okay so to to that
end
i i'd like to just see an informal show
of hands of the committee
on whether or not
you think that the
scope should be extended to include
physical abuse only because that was the
the new new thing in the scope today and
mr chairman isn't that already in this
proposed build that we had before us
today that it includes physical beings
it is but we to to representative lin's
uh uh uh remark
uh we don't have a sense of the
committee specifically on this issue and
it's fairly significant
and so
so i i would like
you to entertain
a request to do a show of hands on
whether or not
the physical abuse addition to the scope
should be included or or if we want to
have that removed you know mr chair can
i could i just ask raise a point of
clarification i
i think what what i was really asking is
i i guess i was and maybe wrongly so but
i was sort of assuming just from the
lack of
comment from other people on the
committee that we were sort of generally
agreed
that that that physical abuse
would be covered my question was more
attorney vicinanzo said it should be
even further than that and that was what
i was you know are we sort of
comfortable what i was really asking is
are we sort of comfortable
leaving it to
sexual abuse and physical abuse and not
going any further than that that was my
question okay okay so so i don't i i'm
fine we'll get there but this first step
in this journey i think is just to find
out if people are okay with adding to
the scope claims that deal strictly with
physical abuse
all right
so uh representative umberger do you
oh okay
so all right so uh raise your hands if
you think the addition of the physical
abuse to the scope of this
uh legislation is something you can
support mr chairman i have a question
before we vote it's representative walls
okay this is just an informal vote by
the way but i still need clarification
does physical infuse accu include
solitary confinement because that would
address the the vote here
so so the next question on this is gets
you what you're asking is the second
vote we're going to take i think to to
explore
representative lin's question about
whether or not we're okay with the
definition
as written
so so you're not i can tell because you
would like solitary confinement included
as part of the definition of physical
abuse i get that i just want to i just
want to do this take two bites of the
apple instead of eating the whole thing
at once
i want to understand what i'm voting on
that's all okay so i'll say it one more
time all we're doing with this raising
of hands is demonstrating whether or not
you support
adding physical abuse by itself as
a basis of filing a claim
because
until we got this version
it was
only sexual abuse in which physical
abuse was a contributing factor
this
version
makes it
its own independent
um
i i'm not a lawyer but
it makes it
open up to its own claim
okay
all right so with that
do you have a question or are you
raising your hand
okay
raise your hand if you think that we
should be adding physical abuse to the
scope of claims
no no no no no no no no
okay
so if you're able to send us something
fairly quickly we can get all that to
ols otherwise i think maybe we'll just
send what they have right now and then
they can work from there i don't know
what your time
okay let me
you have two different versions
that look very similar
yep yeah okay
she should have clarified
okay see there's a difference
not not italicized italicized but other
than that they look kind of similar yeah
so right can i see yeah what you've got
there
it might be this
this one lines up with this right that
one lines up with my green markings over
here
and where did this one come from just
curious hand that out today
so you know i assume from you guys i
don't know this happened the last
meeting as well yeah no because then
long brought something in that also
happened yeah this is just different
yeah because i see this all this
italicized well that's yours that's the
good one
that's the battle this is the one we
oh so you did italicize instead of the
you didn't keep the red lines in it i'm
just going to be careful this is the
second time we've had
documents that don't line up and i can't
you